Three,
two,
one,
boom.
I don't want to start off like this is a commercial dude,
but this fucking thing,
you have this Tim Tam.
This is incredible.
It's sick.
Oh,
I mean I've seen some of these different ones online people using them thera
things and I don't know what they call them.
A third gun I think.
But this fucking thing is amazing.
This is the most powerful one.
It has the the highest travel and is to the best price.
So I mean it's that all the different ones of these things online.
Yeah,
this is the best one.
So what this is folks,
we took the battery out and I'll pop the battery back real quick.
Go for it.
That's how impressed I am by this thing.
So I've had this nagging muscle in my hip and then like instantaneously
you hold it folks and you'd get it like right on the spot.
For me.
It's like right here.
It just loosens that motherfucker up.
Like this is so much more powerful than they need.
Those massages that you get like from a store.
Exactly.
Don't move.
There's no massage are more powerful than this one on the market
from mom and dad.
You know,
this is where the guy doing a,
you know,
playing soccer,
football,
MMA,
crossfit,
that's for the hardcore athletes.
And you invented this?
I started the company,
I started the company.
I bought one of those dms,
I don't know if you ever heard of those.
It's called deep muscle stimulator.
It's kind of talking about that before.
And I said save this,
save this.
[inaudible] exactly.
So what is that?
The deep muscle stimulator.
It's like a stainless steel high powered massager that you have to plugin.
It cost me three grand.
I bought it.
It had a really bad Sadeka for two years.
Like I almost stopped training.
Like I almost had to take a like a got a problem with that right now.
Really sad and okay this is going to help you out.
Big Time comes and goes big time.
I mean I was,
I was so bad I couldn't sleep like I could not sleep because I was just go all
the way.
I get mine in my calf sometimes really lucky all the way down to the calf for
some weird reason me and went down to the hamstring and it stopped there.
Like I,
I was able to stop the problem there,
but they say you can go all the way down to the calf.
That's,
that's getting bad,
you know,
get my cat right now.
So I bought that.
Yeah.
Mess.
There it is.
You know,
that's the DMS.
Great,
great machine,
great machine.
But it overheats.
It costs three grand.
And what does that Piston Dude,
is it hammer you or how much do you it has this like this.
Yeah,
but it has a lesser travel.
This one has a greater travel.
So that one,
the DMS is a little bit to vibration.
It's not as much travel.
It's not as much percussion.
Percussion is which you're looking for.
And so when I got together with a company from the u s disrupt,
we put together the Tim Tam.
Dot.
Tech Company.
We went to
China,
we checked out a hundred different type of guns.
We've got this one going.
This was the best one.
And,
uh,
this fucking things in crowd.
It's incredible.
And I hate to sound like this is like paid me to do an endorsement.
He didn't folks,
this is this fucking thing you should sell.
These should be flying off the chart.
They shouldn't even need drones.
They should just be flying themselves.
So,
so,
you know what the thing was that deep muscle stimulators,
we had to share it in the gym.
This is,
you buy your own personal gun,
you know,
and cause the deep muscle stimulator,
it's 3000 bucks,
you know,
to lend it out.
Or how much is one of these four?
It's 400 bucks.
It's a five year warranty.
That's a fucking bargain.
It's a bargain buddy who trains really hard.
That's a bargain.
It's a massage for life.
It's your health,
you know?
That's nice man.
It's like a saw saw.
Exactly.
Like you took a saws all and you put like a little rubber ball in the end of it.
It's like we tried so many other type of machines,
but they're all overheat week,
you know,
they're not efficient.
The most efficient is already been created.
So we just retooled it.
We just re changed it.
We made it so that it's a,
you can use it on the human body.
There's some modifications made,
but that's it.
I mean it's pretty simple.
It's,
it's the most efficient type of design they have.
Yeah,
it's kind of,
it's really hard to find someone who can massage you correctly.
It's very hard to find someone as good.
Exactly.
Someone who could really break up the tissue.
But even if you do like what this thing can do,
this thing is like vibrating you and shaking everything loose and I have a,
I have a cone tip I got to send you.
It's even goes even deeper.
So if he can handle deep tissue,
I'm going to send you a bunch of them.
Okay.
Yeah,
you're going to love it.
We have also cold tip,
hot tip.
It's a,
it's of your freezer.
You can freeze them because that helps kill the pain.
So if you have an acute acute injury like an after like a week or two and you
want to start working on it,
the cold of the tip helps numb the pain.
It helps manage pain a little more and the hot tip helps loosen up the muscle a
little further.
I mostly used the content,
the context for those who have the,
your experience with massage,
you're,
you're able to go deep tissue and uh,
for some people that hurts.
For me it's,
it's,
it's perfect.
Yeah.
So you find like where the scar tissue is actually break it up.
Exactly.
The surface area on the quantum is obviously smaller so it goes even deeper and,
and uh,
and unlocks that muscle real quick.
So for me,
I don't have the time for foam rolling.
You know,
that's the main reason why I,
I wanted a product like this cause foam rolling takes forever to break to really
loosen up a muscle and I'm in the gym all day.
Do I want to stay in the gym another hour rolling up and down on a,
on a foam roller.
I think you got to do something though,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
Kind of have to do something.
If you're training hard and you want to train for life,
do you use those?
What?
We don't have one in the room,
but the reason those,
um,
what are they calling supernova?
Look a little cross bog balls,
but it's larger and it's like a big blue one.
I love that thing.
It's rogue makes it,
that fucker gets in there,
but this is even better than that.
This thing is incredible.
I like the ball for my back.
When I do my back,
I feel like in light down on it,
I can get the pressure I want,
but when I use,
when I do my legs,
I used the Tim time.
Yeah.
When I go on the road,
I bring that ball with me and I'll put it on the ground in a hotel room and I
bridge on it just like hit like certain spots to amazing pop everything loose
and you need a lot of body weight.
Sometimes I put a kettle bell on my chest and you get even deeper.
Mm.
And
uh,
you could really unlock a muscle like this.
I mean,
it could really get in there and really unlock it for people who train.
They know,
you know when you,
what'd you get out of that nagging tight muscle in your neck and your shoulder,
your shoulder blades.
Yeah.
And then you're on the mat.
You do a quick movement,
you know,
that's scary.
So I did it once in the shower or it's something going on in my neck or gas and
I didn't realize how bad it was and I turned the shower to get something and
then for like days I was locked up.
I've had that done also,
but it's,
it's all about keeping the muscles loose.
Yeah.
Good posture.
You know,
Kelly started wrote a book,
you had him on on the show.
He's really amazing guy.
He's great.
He really changed my life.
Honestly.
I have to,
I'm thinking of reading his book,
supple Leopard.
I know all my,
all,
everybody who knows me follows me.
They know.
I always talk about this book,
you know,
he said something so important.
He said,
look,
it comes down to two things.
Good alignment and loose muscles.
You got to keep your body aligned and loose muscles and a,
I just followed those two principles.
I mean,
his book is really,
really excellent.
And when I saw his,
when I read his book,
that's when I reached out to him to work with George because he,
I don't know if you've ever seen,
when George does a back flip and he lands,
he's,
and he's always kind of come in together.
If you ever see like watch him do a backflip that's called the,
I was reading his book and I saw that's the vulgus fault.
He calls that the Volk is fault when you're,
when you do a squat in your knees,
come close to one another.
And he's like,
that took him cause ACL tears.
And I'm like,
I know a guy with two ACL tears and he does that all the time.
I see him do that all the time.
It's something I've always noticed about George.
He's knees always bow.
And when we do lifts,
when we do jumps,
when we do hurdles,
I mean,
I've watched Jay,
Georgia jumped up and done literally thousands of times and I saw his knees
battling all the time and he's like,
well,
then I reached out to him.
I said,
hey,
could you help me correct Georges?
There it is.
That's the vault,
his fault.
And he's like,
sure.
And ever since then,
Georgia needs it had been a lot better and we still do to fix it.
Well what he does,
it's a technical skill.
It's a skill.
So he does,
he has a few different exercises to help you correct it.
So you put a band around your knees and you kind of push out on the band.
But really what we do is we'll make Georgia do a lift or a jump film it,
send it to Kelly and he'll tell us how aligned we are and what directions to go.
So he kind of coaches us on how to avoid,
uh,
um,
this,
uh,
fault.
However it really,
at the end of the day,
it's about keeping your knees turn to the outside.
I used to walk up the stairs and have needs in my pain in my knee.
You ever have that when you walk upstairs?
No.
I used to have pain in my knee walking up the stairs and that was from stairs
just from walking upstairs and I didn't know why.
And then when I read his book and he's like,
look,
when you walk up a step,
you got to keep your toes straight to and turn your knee out.
I was like,
really?
And I started doing that.
My pain was gone immediately.
Keep your toe straight,
right?
Like toes turn your knee out,
turn you need to the outside.
So he says,
look,
this is your,
this is your ACL.
See this year,
Cross your ECL,
ECL,
you put it in your kneecap,
that's your knee.
When you turn your knee to the outside,
look at,
tightens it up.
That takes away all the slack.
So what happens when you're going up the,
when you're going up the stairs,
your,
your ACL is just jiggling around and getting sheered.
When when you tighten it up,
you go up,
you're secured.
So he calls it creating Torque is a brilliant book.
Mine is brilliant guy.
So even when you run hills,
you should do that.
Absolutely.
You should always be a,
whenever your body is under pressure or stress,
whether you're wrestling or whatnot,
you should always have torque.
So like,
look,
grab your shirt like this.
Okay,
grab your shirt.
he gives an example in the book.
Excellent example.
So now grab the shirt and twist it here.
Create torque.
Now look,
you have a much more uh,
stable grip.
You know,
like a judoka is always going to grab the lapels and twist them.
So when you grab the bar,
let's,
you're going to do a bench press.
Maybe you know,
it's not the best exercise or not,
but the principles still at work,
when you got the bar,
you should be torquing the bomb most.
When you're doing pushups,
your hands are on the mat and you're torquing even though your hands are not
turning,
literally you just torquing.
When you do that,
you feel that all the slack is eaten up,
there's no more slack,
there's no more a trampoline effect.
You know,
there's no more jiggling.
Everything's tight,
the system is tight and it's very,
very important that the system be tight and then the weight beyond the muscles.
So if you're properly aligned,
when you're doing a maneuver,
the weight is on the bone,
not on attendance.
So if you put your,
put your weight like this on your fingers,
you'll see that the bone is carrying the word.
If you bent,
if you bend your bones here,
look at,
look,
if you're on the line and you start putting pressure,
nice,
your muscles are starting to work overtime.
So when I'm carrying weight,
I need to,
I need to have it on my bones and or my muscles,
never on the tendons and ligaments,
you know,
they can then share with backpackers,
backpackers,
do they,
they,
they keep their legs as stiff as possible and they take short,
like sort of short steps.
Like guys who are mountain near guys,
they don't take like big high steps.
They kind of keep their legs stiff and they walk with their skeleton,
right?
If trying to let their scale and see me,
I'm sitting on this chair,
this chair has no muscles,
but it's holding me up because of the structure structures,
that type of,
of uh,
strength.
Though.
If you take an egg and you try to squeeze it in a certain way,
you can't break it.
You know,
you ever seen that experiment?
Why?
Because you're actually trying to crush a cylinder to crush a sinner.
That takes a tremendous amount of force.
However,
to break a stick and half takes very little amount of force.
Why?
And has a lot to do with the,
with the structure.
If you're trying to compress manner on itself,
it won't,
it won't.
It take a tremendous amount of force to do that.
Tremendous,
tremendous amount of power.
However,
if you want to separate the material by bending it at the middle,
it very easy.
But to compress it,
to compress material on itself,
it takes,
would take a tremendous amount of energy.
So anytime you're going outside of your alignment,
you're allowing things to compress.
Yeah.
That's why it makes so much sense to keep your leg straight when you're hiking.
It's like a horse.
It sleeps right?
He's sleeping.
If he aligns his legs perfectly straight,
he's using structure to hold him up instead of muscular strength.
So,
I mean,
and he,
I remember he had,
you had them on the show and you guys had a very interesting uh,
uh,
conversation and he was talking about front squatting will make you have a great
guard.
But I think you guys miss misunderstood each other actually cause you were like,
no,
France squatting has nothing to do with it.
Have a great garden.
I,
and I agree with both of you,
but I think you guys,
we're not talking about the exact same thing he's talking about having the
mobility
to squat down really low and the front squat,
we'll help you regard not necessarily having a big lift,
but not necessarily,
he wasn't talking about heavy lifting.
300 pounds in the front squat is gonna make you a great guard player that that's
irrelevant.
I think what he was talking about is having credible and mobility in your hips.
You ever see a child pick up something off the floor like a newborn baby?
He's going to get into this perfect,
perfect squat.
Well,
if you,
if you look at guard players,
the best guard players always have incredible flexibility in their hips,
right?
Because I always tell people that the higher you can bring your hips to your
chest,
the hardest for me to pass your guard.
Like if you're one of those guys were,
were your knees like this,
you know,
you're trying to regard and you need it this far.
It's the space for me to pass your guard is huge.
Yeah.
But if you can bring this foot behind your head and your hymns,
it's the window.
The space that I need to cross to get to side control is so small.
Um,
Eddie has a,
excuse me,
one of his students,
his name's Sean Ballinger and he has crazy [inaudible].
I've seen him,
I've seen the double a.
He could do double lotus and literally take his legs and put them behind his
head.
Yeah.
I mean he could just pull those lines back.
How many,
how many great guard players have you seen who can do that?
Swearing like Ryan Hall for instance.
Yeah.
Keenan,
I mean they have this flexibility to them.
Passing the guards becomes very,
very,
it's almost impossible.
Almost impossible.
It's like they just spend a little bit and you're back in something again and
you're,
you're tying up and then you in leg locks and you're kind of fucked anxieties
there as they're spinning to your leg while you're trying to pass their guard.
And hip flexibility is so paramount in Jujitsu for bottom game especially.
And it's so devastating when you have a hip injury,
hip injuries and you know,
I know guys who have had hip replacements and it's like,
boy,
you know,
then you're,
you're so severely limited in what you can do afterwards.
You got to never let it get there.
In my opinion,
according to Kelly,
he says your joints can last you a 120 years.
Like if you take care of them.
He said there's 2% catastrophe,
meaning you got hit by a bus.
Okay,
that's something we can,
we can't do anything about.
98% of the time is because you didn't take care of your joints,
you haven't,
you haven't properly use them and you let muscles get tight for too long over a
long period of time.
So for me personally,
I feel like when I was 20,
I feel better now than when I was 25.
He's at 25.
I was really beat up 26,
27.
I was really like,
hey my knees,
my back,
my neck,
you know,
training everyday.
Twice a day it was grueling.
But after I went through that system,
I came back out fresh and now whenever I have a little tweak or anything like
that,
I take care of it immediately.
I kill it.
I don't let any tweak creep up,
Go Gore he further and uh,
I feel much more energy.
Like when I,
when I keep that,
the body healthier Louis,
I feel a lot more energy.
I feel better.
My mood is better.
That's the,
it's the balance between being tough and,
and you know,
being mentally strong enough to like push through training when you're,
you know,
you're not feeling your best and knowing that you're fucking up your vehicle
when you're knowing that you're fucking up your body.
Very true.
There's a balance hard for fighters in particular because they want to be tough,
you know?
So you've got some weird little thing in new leg or whatever.
I'm just going to work through it and just were,
and you say,
I'm just going to like that,
which is hilarious.
People who say they're going to go,
like you go light and then you get tagged and then you want to get some of that
and the next thing you know you're not going light.
And then that thing and your leg,
it's all fucked up.
And then next thing you know,
you go to a doctor and know you have an MCL tear.
Ah,
fuck.
Yup.
And then what that tightness that's,
it gets worse after,
after 48 hours,
you have dlms,
delayed onset muscle soreness,
and then you're in the shower,
you turn your neck,
boom,
something pops.
Yeah,
yeah.
What do you do in terms of dictates or Cunanan or cocoon.
Cocoon.
That's how you say it,
right?
Kirk Koonin,
Tumeric,
anti-inflammatory,
you know,
herbs and things along those lines.
I know that,
um,
there was Rhonda,
Patrick just put something up about,
uh,
I think you see,
I think you called curcumin circling or Kirk Kirk Cunanan.
Anyway,
it's Tumeric.
It's the active ingredient in tumeric and she just puts something up on her,
a Twitter page a couple of days ago about how important this stuff is and to
make sure that you have a bioavailable,
improves memory and mood as well.
Well,
I'll have to try it.
I haven't tried it.
Yeah,
it's just to Merrick.
It's uh,
and yeah,
and that stuff is fantastic for inflammation.
People that have soreness and you know,
like nagging injuries and nagging inflammation,
having that as a part of your daily diet is fantastic.
Along with fish oil.
Fish oil is really good for that,
you know,
of course.
And then watching your diet and making sure you're low and inflammatory foods
like sugar and alcohol and really it's amazing how much of a difference it
makes.
Huge if you have any sort of a back injury or inflammation.
I talked to this lady who was a therapist a few years back and she was saying,
you know,
you should really try going gluten free if you have issues with your,
uh,
with your back.
I was like,
listen,
this wacky pitch,
that's what I was thinking.
All those things.
It's like,
oh,
she's talking woo woo,
Woo Crystal's nonsense.
And I was like,
wait a minute.
Really?
Gluten.
She's like,
you'd be amazed at how many people,
um,
when,
and now that I've thought about it more and with all I know,
talking to various nutritionists and actual clinical researchers,
I think it's as much gluten as it is just just sugar,
refined carbohydrate hydrates and refined carbohydrates and sugars and all these
different things.
Just create inflammation.
There's just no way around it.
Especially the,
the levels that normal Americans eat a man.
Oh boy.
Yeah.
You're talking about where the worst,
yeah,
it's,
it's tremendous amount of sugar.
Yeah.
You don't know it until you get off sugar and then you go see everybody who is
eating the standard amount of sugar and you're like,
it blows your mind.
Yeah.
You don't need that much sugar.
Still Way does it.
It's just way too much.
And you'll feel sick eating that much sugar again.
Like it's just,
it's mind boggling.
Like a Jug Gatorade,
the love doing drink after practice.
I didn't get that down.
I mean if you ever seen those,
they have those things where they show you a in I'm on uh,
online.
They have like this is the amount of sugar that's in a can of coke.
This is the amount of sugar that's in a 24 bottle of Gatorade.
It's fucking crazy.
It's incredible amount of pile is sugar.
It's unbelievable.
It's like a fist full of sugar,
but it's addictive.
Yeah.
Customer coming back.
Yes.
The customer coming back.
You need that next sugar high.
You need a more sugar than next time around and you need another dose of sugar
and I think,
I think you should,
you should get it from whole foods mostly in.
It gets released in your system naturally.
Slowly.
There it is right there.
Look at that.
Wow.
Big Gulp is like a,
it's like a key low.
Wow.
It's like,
like you bringing coke across the border.
That's just poisonous.
Fucking amazing.
That's so much a girl.
That's impressive.
What does it say?
17 grams.
What does it say,
Jamie?
30 17 table.
1732 tables for that.
This is 18 tables.
See Jesus Christ.
Wow.
It's so much sugar.
Some milk.
Wow.
Chocolate milk's supposed to be good after you train though.
White milk to,
well,
maybe that's old news.
Uh,
I dunno,
George used to do that.
Yeah.
George used to that.
But I'll tell you something.
George is a freak of nature when it comes to diet.
Yeah.
He,
he's very blessed.
Okay.
I think,
uh,
I think this,
look,
this is just my observation,
but I think some people,
um,
when they eat carbs,
they spike the insulin.
Okay.
And they can get fat off if they eat too much carbs.
And some people will eat a tremendous amount of carbs and they never get fat.
And we've all had,
we all have a friend who eats a lot of junk.
Food is ripped.
They're not,
they're not many in the,
in the world.
Okay.
But they exist.
You've all,
we've all met a person like that.
Georgia is one of those guys.
Like if he eats Mcdonald's for a week or he eats vegetables for a week,
it doesn't matter.
He's going to be lean either way.
Now he'd be leaner on vegetables.
But even on Mcdonald's,
he's going to be lean.
He's never been fat and his entire career,
his entire life,
I should say so I mean get a little heavier.
When he stopped training it look,
cause he took some photos for the UFC.
He looked a little heavier.
Bulky,
I would say.
Would you say that he's Chubby?
No,
no,
no.
I saw him at the beach.
I wouldn't say we like this guy's shredded,
that guys,
Jack,
Jack Guys,
Jack.
They show it.
It's George.
You hold them to the highest of standards.
You know,
if I hate the way he eats,
I would be fat.
Why?
Let's put it that way.
How many people told me,
hey,
I had been hanging out with George for a week.
I got fat,
I gained 10 pounds.
I'm like,
yeah,
that's George Man.
That's George.
You don't,
don't eat like he eats.
You won't.
It won't work.
And he has his whole theories and philosophies all about why he's leaving.
It's like,
dude,
no,
you're just,
you're just born this way.
[inaudible] this doesn't get it.
I've like,
I've trained thousands of people.
Okay.
He's trained himself like he thinks that way.
He went,
he did.
What he did is we're going to work for everyone.
And I love Georgia Super Intelligent Guy,
but I tell him during the week,
like he's very gifted when it comes to food and he does a lot of things and like
now he's doing a lot of fasting and he's getting even leaner,
but it would be a long time for Georgia's fat.
Do you see that there's,
there's,
there's various body types.
You know,
you do have ectomorph Mesomorph endomorph and we're,
we're uh,
we're on the continuum of these three is on the Ectomorph side and a,
in a,
in a strong sign of ectomorph is a small waist and George has a Mesomorph no
mesomorph cause he's very muscular.
He is.
I would,
you become more active,
more Schwab
muscles,
but sorry.
Yeah,
go ahead.
George was very skinny and scrawny when he was young,
so he went crazy on the weights.
He turned his weakness into a strength.
He,
that's so much weight,
weight training and exercise because he wanted to bulk up.
So he's a bulk ectomorph now.
He's not a perfect outcome.
He's not 100% up to more of,
I would say it's between Ectomorph Mesomorph,
endomorph the,
the other end of the spectrum.
You eat a little bit of a carbohydrate to get fat,
you lift a little bit of muscles,
your muscles explode in size.
The George wasn't like that.
Georgia is a bit on the other side of the spectrum.
So a real mesomorph would be like Melvin Manhoef.
Uh,
yeah.
Like that,
you know,
I think I'm kind of no,
no,
no.
That's more uh,
uh,
endomorph endomorph it's fat.
Yeah.
But you could also be very muscular and morph.
You can be very muscular.
I thought endomorph is like,
like people that have a really hard time not being overweight.
You can gain fat and muscle really quickly as an endomorph.
Yeah.
But ectomorphs from what I've read,
I might be wrong.
Neither one of us are biologists.
Exactly.
I always thought Ectomorph is really skinny.
Endomorph was they tend to lean towards being overweight and then Mesomorph for
someone who's like really like a Francis and Ghana,
not super ma or Brock Lesnar like super muscular,
thick,
like just look like they like naturally would pack a lot of mosques.
I'm sure you could pull up a chart if you,
if you can't,
all these pictures just show both of them from what I,
from what I've read,
see them as amorphous,
kind of in the middle.
ECTOMORPH is Ilene and hot pack on muscle.
Ectomorph looks like a skinny dork and Mesomorph looks like he's super jacked
and endomorph looks like,
well endomorph endomorph does not look fat in that picture.
He doesn't have to be fat.
That's the thing.
Now here,
here's,
let me tell you something ladies.
When you look at those three pictures,
I go with endomorph all day.
Exactly.
Those three pictures,
if that's what an endomorph is,
let's take that in the morning.
Yeah.
Because they need a lot of naps and they're always tired.
And those mesomorphs their egos,
Mike,
they want to choke you.
The mesomorph shoulders you want to fucking strangle you.
But,
uh,
endomorphs that's a woman.
God,
you can have a rift endomorph anybody can be ripped.
That's the guy's an endomorph.
Maybe think about it in the morph is like a short,
stocky hulk.
I should be fat.
And he could also be packed with muscle,
like the Calvin Kelvin gassed alum,
Kevin Gasol.
And he would only put them on the end of the moves and the more site.
Yes,
definitely.
Because he's never really totally ripped while dolce when he had him and he was
getting them down to a real one 70,
he,
he really had,
I'm pretty ripped at one point in time.
Just really low body.
You can get ripped.
It's just not as easy to get there.
Anybody can get ripped.
But uh,
an ectomorph.
So think about a basketball player.
Okay.
One of the signs they say is small waist.
The waist and shoulders are quite similar.
Now George has a v going,
you know,
is very broad shoulders,
which is great.
He's perfectly built for fighting that allows him for reach and his Aa cause
he's got incredible like this.
He's wearing shoulder pads
almost.
And you know,
he's blessed with many,
many,
uh,
genetic gifts for fighting,
no doubt about it.
And endomorphs are naturally predisposed,
excuse me.
ECTOMORPHS are naturally predisposed to endurance sports.
So you'll see a lot of marathon runners or whatnot.
They're tall and lanky.
They're not short,
bulky,
you know,
Mike Tyson type look athletes.
That's a real,
that's a real,
that's what I would say.
Endomorph endomorph because he's so short,
short and stocky and bulky.
He could put on a lot of muscle,
a lot of fat Nasco.
Is he a little bit,
I don't want to,
I don't want to say he's fat,
whether he's,
he's put on some fat since he's a retired or whatnot.
Right.
I don't know how much it works out anymore,
you know?
Exactly.
But an Ectomorph,
even when they stop working out,
they're still,
they're less likely to put pack on fat.
And I have a little belly,
you know,
but it's not as as pronounced.
It's not as pronounced as an endomorph and more full pack on fat and muscle real
quickly.
And they're,
they're more,
um,
they gravitate more towards power sports so they can explode,
but we'll have less.
They have less cardio.
Where's the ECTOMORPH is like,
you'll see a lot of running backs.
They're short,
stocky,
and the morph,
man,
they have to explode for three,
four seconds.
Is there a best body for fighting or is there a,
do you just adapt your style to whatever body you exactly.
I think there's the best body for basketball.
The best body for football.
While it depends on what position you're playing,
but fighting,
everybody has an a fight in their DNA.
So all styles,
excuse me,
all body types can fight.
And that's what's so amazing.
You got it.
You got to Paul Harris.
He's an endomorph man,
but he found a way to fight that make sense for him.
That's what I always tell people.
You got to fight according to your,
your body type.
And people think that's crazy.
No,
Muhammad Ali fought a certain way because it has certain attributes.
He had certain,
he had certain,
uh,
a certain personality.
Even your personalities are important.
If he tried to fight Mike Tyson,
it would backfire.
If Tyson tried to fight like Muhammad Ali,
I think everybody has to start with the basics and then after three,
four years of training,
even maybe up to five years now,
you got a specialized for what your temperament is,
what's your body type is,
what your personality is.
Because not everybody wants to get it done and run one and not everybody's the
type of person who's going to take it to the cards and not everybody has a reach
and speed to jab in and out.
Luckily we think,
oh,
I'm just going to jab in and out like I'll eat.
Do it.
Do you have the attributes that Ali has?
He was born with certain attributes and everybody's born with an attribute for
fighting.
In my opinion,
everybody got this far because they can fight.
Nobody got here,
uh,
this far without having some innate ability to fight,
to defend themselves.
So all our body types can defend themselves,
but you have to discover what works best for that body type.
Would Tyson is a perfect example.
Exactly.
They thought you couldn't make it in the pools if I'd always going to get killed
in the pros bright.
There's never been a short guy.
When when Ali was dancing around,
people are like,
no,
that's not going to work.
He's going to get tired and he goes to the heavyweights heavyweight shouldn't
bounce around and at least to spar a lot with lightweights,
he sparse six rounds with light weights,
then six rounds with a heavyweight.
Why?
Because he would play tag with a lightweight.
It just about speed and movement.
You move twice as much with the lightweight.
What is your thoughts on on hard sparring?
Because when you see the ties in the way they spar,
there's some,
there's a great benefit in that.
I mean there's a great benefit in that barely hitting each other shit.
I do that.
I do tremendous amount of that.
You know,
one thing when people spar with me,
they're like,
man,
you move.
So like,
you know,
people are like,
it's so seamless the way you move.
And I,
I do thousands of hours of live rolling,
inspiring,
but a lot of those hours,
I would say 80% of them is very light because I know the terrain.
I just want to go through the sequences as many times as I can and when I'm
really,
really warmed up,
then I'll go heart in all start talking smack a bit in the gym and I'm like,
oh my,
let's see what you got and I'll,
I'll,
I'll tell the guy when it's time to go really hard and we're having fun with it.
You know?
For me,
having fun is really,
really important.
Now that's training for longevity,
but if you have a fight,
I think you need to do six weeks of hard sparring.
Why?
Because the speed of the fight is very particular.
We need to get to fight speed,
the actual speed of the fight because you might get caught sleeping if you,
if you haven't done that now,
if you have a tremendous amount of fight experience,
you don't need the less of that.
So,
for instance,
a tie who has been fighting since he's eight years old.
He can tune up just on the path and go fight.
Why he's been doing it since the day he can.
He can walk,
you know,
almost like you look at a Mayweather.
I can get me with already with just a little Mitt work,
put them in there.
He's going to be at a world champion.
Why?
It's,
it's hardwired.
If you look at a baby's brain,
the baby's brain is not wrinkled like a heat,
like an adult's brain.
It's wrinkled to us of small degree.
As he goes through his experiences,
especially in the first three years of his life,
his brain literally gets hardwired and wrinkled and it gets less and less
wrinkled over time and when you're hardwired to do something you,
the likelihood of you needing to tune up is,
it's very,
it's very minimal.
Like,
for instance,
I remember looking at the biography of me whether,
and he was saying when he would go to picnics with his family,
his father would bring boxing gloves and he,
his box with his cousins.
They literally will be punching each other's for him.
You know,
he's,
he's been doing it so long.
The more experienced you are,
the less hard sparring you need.
The more seasoned you are,
You know what fighting is.
You just need a little tuneup at the end.
So if you look at Georgia,
Georgia,
great example,
he's super skilled and he's super healthy.
Some guys get to the high skill level,
but they're broken up.
Their body's broken,
their knees broken.
They can barely,
I barely have three,
four fights left in them,
right?
Do you want to get really,
really good and then be broken?
What you,
when you got there,
you finally,
you know,
you've been cultivating these skills for 15 years.
You get there,
you get those skills that you want it all.
I can't use them.
Why am I,
the machine is broken.
You know,
I'm,
I'm 38.
I feel like I,
when I was 20,
uh,
personally because I spar 80% of my sparring is very flow and relaxed.
Like I use a lot of,
I train a lot with purple belts,
Bluebell Zinpro belts.
Why?
Because they kind of hurt me if they tried,
I just toy with them till I'm warmed up,
I'm flowing.
I'm not really working,
harms flowing,
I'm just doing my combinations.
And
then when I really want to have a good challenge,
I'll take one of the most elite guys,
one of my pros and I'll do one or two rounds with them.
You know,
I won't burn my machine out.
like imagine driving your car and the red line all the time.
Yeah.
Now that's a great way of looking at it.
When you,
when you guys get ready for a fight,
like say if you get George ready for a fight,
how much time do you spend on working on his recovery from the workouts?
Like,
like how do you bust out the Tim Tam Machine and ice things down?
Like how aware of you or are you guys have like do you have,
I guess a regimented program of how to recover from exercise?
Recovery is everything.
So it's,
it's stress plus recovery equals adaptation.
Stress Plus Stress Equals d training and an injury.
Yeah,
a good trainer,
a good trainer.
He understands super compensation rate.
You have stress,
you have recovery,
and then you have a new level of skill or ability.
If you don't go through the recovery phase,
you will not reap the rewards of your training or has to be a recovery phase.
Not every athlete has a level of recovery that they can,
they can achieve.
So as you get,
as you get more experience as an athlete,
your body can can,
as you become,
uh,
as you're,
as you're more and more fit,
I should say,
your body can recover for more stress.
So I have to gauge how good mice my student is.
It has to be challenging but manageable.
If I make it too challenging,
I'm red lining him.
He's going to break,
he's and he's going to pop.
He's going to be unmotivated.
If it's too easy,
it's going to be bored.
I have to find the right amount of stimulus.
So when I'm in the practice room,
if I see Georgia just mauling guys and destroying them,
I have to make it,
I have to scale the workout so that it's harder,
but I don't want to scale it so high is that I injure him and break him or that
he made out of practice by a hair and now he's not motivated to do another camp.
You know,
we,
we reached those high intensity levels periodically throughout the year and they
have to be done in a certain way that it's fun.
Like you know,
George was like,
he was on your show and he was saying,
I'll try to kill them in the practice room
now.
It's true.
He's right.
But I do it so rarely.
I do so periodically and I make it a joke.
That's why like what he was trying to say is that I brought in the guys in the
room and I was watching him spar with Georgia.
They don't want to touch his face.
This is when he was like a mega star,
like he was the champion.
Nobody wants to try to double leg him.
Nobody wants to try to hurt him because they're like,
I'm not going to come here in his house and tried to show him.
There's a respect thing.
There's a,
there's a,
there's starstruck,
you know,
these young kids salad,
bring them in.
And I'd be like,
listen guys,
I'll give a speech.
The first guy to double leg,
I'm the first guy to put 'em out.
I would put like a $5,000 reward,
uh,
I think knock him out and the hurt,
if you've knocked George,
I'll give you 5,000 bucks.
And she leaves for George on his back.
If you put George on his back,
if you take them down,
put them on his back,
I'll stop the whole practice and praise you for 20 minutes in front of everybody
in the gym.
And,
and,
and students don't get praised by me very often.
So George would be like,
oh my God,
these guys,
they're coming after me.
And he would get riled up.
And I will do this periodically.
Rarely,
right?
We're,
we're,
we're talking about world class,
world title fight,
you know,
the stuff's on the line.
And I need these guys to actually show me where is missing something because
then when you have this perfect practice and you win all the time,
what do you work on?
Well,
nothing went wrong.
There's nothing to fix.
So I mean,
there are times where we really red light.
Have you ever had anybody knock him out and practice and take that money?
Now he's been dropped once in practice pretty badly.
And it's a funny story,
but the money wasn't on the line that time.
There was no price for that.
One time he got dropped in practice and um,
I want it to stop.
I want to pull the plug.
It was for a world title fight.
He was fighting that hardy two weeks before his fight.
I was sure he was concussed.
And I said,
George,
I'm pulling the,
the,
the round one more round.
He said to me,
coach,
let me finish the round.
I'm okay.
Let me finish the next round.
And I felt that if I pulled him,
I would have killed his confidence.
Totally.
So I said,
okay,
you could do the next round.
And I told the other guy,
he was sparring with Dolan line a single glove.
Like I whispered to him,
not a single glove on it,
just take a mauling and George went in the next round not knowing that the other
guy is not allowed to hit him at all.
He just crushes the guy.
Right.
He's just like mauls him and gets that and I was really,
really grateful for that.
That guy,
that guy was a pro and it was very,
very grateful that he took the beating that we asked them to write and I'm
joined.
You have to was like,
man,
I know,
I know it went bad and round four but Ron five was amazing.
I was on fire.
North acid.
You weren't.
You were,
you were.
I think sneaky shit.
He's like,
I have.
I,
wow.
That was brought forward was not,
it was just a fluke.
You know,
like this,
this is,
this is what I'm going to look like around five,
you know,
I'm like,
yeah.
He's like,
it's a good thing.
It's Friday,
you know,
because I have the day off tomorrow.
I'm like George,
today's Saturday.
It's like wow.
He was shocked.
He was like,
did he Saturday?
I'm like,
yeah.
And,
and the,
the UFC was there filming
so I had to like,
look guys,
that footage can never air,
you know,
that foot has got to disappear.
You know?
They're like,
yeah,
don't worry.
No,
we understand the fights on the line.
He was fighting Darren hardy two weeks later.
That's why that fight,
he was doing a lot of wrestling cause we didn't want to like even chance.
I was sure he had a concussion when he went in that fight.
Now pulling the plug on that fight on a lot of people would be like,
hey,
you put his leg,
you put his health on the line.
You're right.
But it's so much pressure.
First of all,
George didn't want,
that has nothing to do with UFC.
We kept it from UFC.
Like we told them,
like,
we told the camera guys,
Barry this like,
don't report it.
Like George would never want to,
uh,
back out of that fight.
It was two weeks from now.
Everybody's coming to watch us fight like this despite,
you know,
it's been,
it's been on the,
uh,
what do you call it?
The prime time.
It's been like three weeks.
They're filming,
you know,
like this is happening,
this fight is happening no matter what.
You know,
the Georges in that mindset.
And uh,
but he went in there honestly like,
uh,
you know,
after he got dropped pretty badly.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's,
you know,
Forrest Griffin got knocked out twice before his fight with Anderson Silva man
twice.
And apparently one of them was real bad.
Really?
Yeah.
It's dangerous.
I think he was sparring with Vandelay and uh,
apparently you don't spar with Vandelay?
No,
it's just fights.
Yeah.
I mean he's old school shooter box,
especially back then.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Forest won't really talk about too much cause he,
you know,
he doesn't want it doesn't want it to be perceived as an excuse,
but he,
uh,
I mean,
how many times have fighters done that?
Many,
many factors has done that.
Countless.
Yeah.
To the point where like I just let the fighter,
the site now,
unless I really feel like it's urgent,
which is rare that I've actually had to intervene because at the end of the day,
when are you 100% it's really rarely happens.
There's always something.
Right.
But the thing about getting knocked out is that if you get knocked out two weeks
ago,
your odds of getting knocked out or significantly higher.
I know,
I know.
Man.
It's,
it's,
it's crazy.
And then Hardy's a really good strike.
Oh my God.
That left hook.
If it would have touched George,
George will would have been out like a light.
He's got a crazy left hook.
Plus George was hurt two weeks before.
Yeah.
Thank God it worked out well.
It worked out.
Credit.
Yeah.
It's a balancing act of being a trainer is not something that I envy.
No,
it's tough.
It's tough because I care for these guys,
honestly.
Yeah.
They had nothing to do with the business where the money,
I couldn't care less.
I could not care less.
But I know that that guy,
he's on a one way track.
So if I'm telling him no,
hit the brakes and he's saying we're going that that break and harmony is gonna
create a friction and create a doubt in the fighter.
Right.
Know you,
are you all in?
Are you all in?
You know,
because if you're not all in,
you're going to scare your fighter.
Right.
There's,
there's that to consider as well.
Yeah.
Um,
when you look at the crop of up and coming talent,
I mean this is such a crazy time for MMA.
I think when you look at these new guys,
like Zack beat is one of my favorite guys to watch cause he's,
there's these new crop of guys that can do everything and they're,
they're so high level.
By the time you see them,
like the first fight I saw of the beat inside the octagon.
You know,
I've seen him on video before,
but seeing him live you like,
oh Lee Shit,
he's amazing,
but he's not just amazing.
It's like this is,
this is this next level.
Like there's another level,
like we've seen this,
these elite fighters and everyone's great at Jujitsu.
Everyone's got great takedown defense,
everyone knows how to strike,
but then you're seeing this new flavor,
there's like this,
okay,
the frequencies now higher,
and it just seems to me that it every year or so there's these new guys that
jump through and you're going,
okay,
well now the frequencies quite a bit higher than it was before.
It's seamless.
Transitions are more and more seamless,
which is amazing.
Like you're saying,
they're processing it faster.
Yeah.
As they're doing the takedown,
like Demetrius is flowing into an arm bar to take down his even finished and
you're like,
the next generation is watching that and they've adopted that now,
so they're going to flow into a transition into an art.
Like it's,
it's getting,
it's getting more and more seamless.
They're computers or,
or,
or computing faster and faster information.
They're thinking what they're going to do on the ground.
It hits the ground.
It's,
it's,
it is incredible
and they know what can be done now.
They've seen it all possibilities.
So they have this database in their mind of accomplishments that have already
been achieved in other fighters.
Yeah.
He's been awakened.
It's fucking crazy,
man.
When you stop and think about when you first got involved in the sport and then
look at the level to fighters are at now,
there's not really a commensurate sport in terms of like modern mainstream
sports.
Where you've people have achieved is such an incredibly high level of
proficiency that's so far exceeds where it was a decade ago or two decades ago.
There's really no comparison.
The growth rate is ridiculous.
It's fucking amazing.
And I don't think it's a
a coincidence that the growth rate in this sport is incredible and this is the
sport that has the most amount of variables in terms of combat sports,
the most amount of variables in terms of what,
what a fighter can do to you.
There are more ways to win than any other combat sport,
obviously.
Yeah,
and that's why I find it.
See,
the more you limit us an athlete,
the more it's about torque.
So for instance,
if you look at sprinting,
if I were to race Hussein bolt and it had all the best trainers,
the best sprint coaches and Hussein bolt had the most mediocre,
mediocre sprint coaches and we raced when we were both 20 years old in our
prime.
Who's going to win you?
I appreciate the that
the competence.
It's a joke question,
right?
He's going to win for sure.
Put us in MMA.
We're the same way.
Class,
same height,
everything's the same.
I have the best coaches.
He has the worst coaches.
Who's going to win?
You're going to fuck them.
I'm going to kill him because coaching now is has a greater influence.
Sprinter.
Say Sprint coaches say we can make you faster.
We can not make you fast.
You have to be born fast.
That we could shave off a few milliseconds.
Yeah.
In MMA we can make you,
I could take a regular Joe and get them all the way up to UFC.
I can't make him UFC champion.
I won't say I can make them UFC champion to be UFC champion.
You need a talent.
Okay,
there's a,
there's a talent there to be in the 1% but to get you to UFC because there are
so many possibilities.
There are so many ways to trick your opponent are so many ways to turn the
tables on him.
The torque no longer matters or torque is less significant.
So if we're talking about football where I'm only a lot to do these certain
maneuvers trickeries put to the side,
you're not allowed to trick me.
But in MMA you're alleged to trick me any which way you want.
There are very few little rules,
okay.
But outside of these,
these uh,
bard rules is Barton maneuvers.
You can trick me any which way you want.
So what happens is you take your opponent to amaze you,
take your opponent into a world where torque does it matter so much.
And that's why the more restrictive,
uh,
a sport is,
let's say for instance,
boxing.
Boxing is more restrictive than Moitai.
So the guys with Torque,
we're going to do better in boxing.
Then they will necessarily end Moitai cause in what I can use more trickery.
I can be a little dweeb and just beat you with clinching.
Or I could beat you with a trick kick or I could beat you with a back.
A back.
La Friends is a back kick.
Anybody can generate knockout power with a backache.
However,
with a Red Cross or left hook,
not everybody's going to have that bone crushing power.
However,
if you teach somebody how to throw a proper backache,
which you know,
cause you've got the best back in the game,
you could teach a regular Joel in a few years how did generate knockout power?
So now he,
he has that element on the table.
So because MMA soul,
um,
uh,
you know,
there's so few rules we have a greater environment for the intellect to,
to,
to shine.
Hmm.
You said something wants to one of your fighters in between rounds and they
really stood out.
You said,
I want you to overwhelm his mind with possibilities like your,
your,
your overwhelming him.
You're making him think about all the potential variables that are coming his
way.
Right.
My Dad has a great way to put it.
We talk about
to,
um,
a variety.
So everybody's looking for a pattern.
If I do Jab,
Jab,
cross,
and I do with before times,
the fourth time you're going to see it.
It's going to be slower to you.
Why?
Because your body's going to your brain is,
is that again,
this is all hypothetical.
This is just my personal experience.
I'm basing this on my own personal experience.
When somebody does something to me a second or third time it,
I see it personally.
I feel like I'm perceiving it slower and I have a window to counter you.
However,
when I spar with George,
George is a tricky as guy.
I'll tell you why,
because he's,
he has so many tricks.
Yes.
So many attacks that he rarely,
rarely ever shows you the same trick twice.
And he's the master at adapting.
So if you do a trick on him once and you try it again,
he's going to shut you down.
So look at all his rematches.
When you read Bj Penn,
when you were,
you matched Matt.
He was,
every time they read much,
it was progressively worse.
The third time you fought my heels was even easier.
Don't try the same trick on George twice.
You're going to get crushed.
And I think that's why meal as a,
as a martial arts,
I developed like a lot of variety of skill because every week I'd have to come
up with a new trick or as George is going to shut that down.
After 10 years I've been started becoming like a trickster.
You know,
what other magic trick can I get away with one time because next week I need a
new trick because it won't work on him again.
He's eating,
he's going to get wise to it.
He's a master at add.
It might work once on him.
The second time you're going to get shut down.
Well I feel like that
was a factor in Dominick Cruz losing to Cody Garbrandt.
Exactly.
Cause those Alpha male guys had seen that check so many times.
Okay.
We can like,
apparently Justin Buchholz can imitate Dominick Cruz in training like that weird
Herky jerky movement with the hands down.
Exactly.
He's a weird one,
man.
He's one of the weird at all the fighters I've ever watched fight.
Dominic might be the weirdest.
I agree.
Cause you,
you look at him and he's,
first of all,
he's such a,
he's a great guy.
Very smart guy.
But he's crazy and a weird way.
It's like one of the things that he said is like,
hi,
I'm just not very flexible.
Like what are you,
why are you even saying that?
Like,
that doesn't even make any sense to me.
Like why not get more flexible?
It's like,
it's not like saying like,
Oh,
uh,
I'm too short.
Well you can't grow so you're fucked.
You know you're never gonna to play basketball saying I'm not flexible enough.
It's like easy fix.
That's the dumbest thing to ever say.
I mean it's so,
it's so much more dumb than I'm not strong enough.
We will,
if you gain weight from muscle,
you might not be in that weight class anymore.
You've got a real problem there,
but I'm not flexible and if you got zero problem,
you just have to stretch.
But he doesn't stretch.
Right.
Like we were talking about Jujitsu techniques,
it's like,
ah,
I can't play that hard guard guard,
high guard shit.
I don't have any flexibility.
Okay,
what are you saying like that doesn't make any sense and like head kicks and
things along those lines.
He's like very stiff in his legs with throwing kicks and like that's,
that's an easy fix.
It's an easy fix.
Why wouldn't you fix that?
That's a good question.
But,
but also the mindset of a champion in this same guy who just just,
fuck it.
I'm not flexible.
I don't even understand how those things live together.
In the same mind if I was treating him,
I would make him head kick.
Like that's what I would insist on.
All of these have to be there cause he doesn't knock guys out with his hands.
So he,
the head kick has to always be a possibility always in Tibet and then you will
knock out guys with your hands because they'll have their high guard up because
they don't want that kick.
And then upper cut,
we'll come.
The body shot will come to the back of the cook.
I'll make it back for sure.
Like if you don't have power in your hands,
you need to backache.
You need to head kick.
Those are two weapons that can always knock a guy out so you don't back.
Your feudal hecky can never score knockouts.
Right?
Yeah.
That's a good point man.
It's uh,
when did you see this Stephen Thompson thing with Darren toe where he wants them
to outlaw that side kick to the knee?
No,
I didn't see that.
Well apparently his knee got really fucked up in the Darren till fight.
You know,
what do,
what do you think about that side kick to the knee that everyone's do not even
the oblique kick.
Just a front leg side kick to the knee the same way you're,
well Romero used it on Robert Whitaker fucked up his knee and the first fight
and then winter could use it on Romero.
Like right away he was stuck in fight.
Beautiful to fuck up his knee.
Um,
I think it's a legitimate kick.
Yeah,
it's a legitimate 100% kick it,
it allows the smaller,
weaker guide to hurt the bigger,
stronger guy.
Well,
in the case of Darren till it allows the bigger,
stronger guy hurt the other big stronger if it works for the smaller guy who
works for the bigger guy.
Yeah,
right.
It's just a legit,
it's,
I think so too.
It's a legit technique you have to prepare for.
Yeah,
exactly.
You're studying in a way that you see when somebody's standing sideways,
they're harder to punch,
they're easier to kick.
So you're saying,
look,
I want to stand in this way where I'm harder to budge,
but I don't want you to kick me.
So if I stand square,
I'm more susceptible to back kick more sub two punches,
but less sub susceptible to leg kicks or the oblique kick or the psychic to the
knee or whatnot.
Now I'm not saying to you,
don't punch me cause I'm more vulnerable this way.
So whatever your vulnerability is,
you chose that vulnerability by standing sideways.
Why don't the Thai stand sideways?
Because they know they're going to get chopped to the leg,
right?
They're always fighting good kickers.
They're always fighting amazing kickers.
When you go to Thailand,
that guy may be a good puncher but he's for sure a great kicker.
Like you're not going to run into a guy who doesn't know how to kick.
They all know how to kick knee and elbow and some of them know how to punch
really,
really well also.
So they stand in away.
Moitai has developed in a way is very anti kick Antony anti elbow and it's not
as defensive to the punches.
So if I want to stand,
if I want to avoid punches,
I'll stand more.
Bladed lets him and fighting it like a Bj Penn was very heavy handed and more of
a puncher.
It doesn't kick much.
Well I'm going to stand bladed like you see what George would made him drop one
hand.
Why?
So he can use his jab from,
from down to up.
Right.
Cause it's faster,
has a greater reach and it's harder to counter.
Whereas if you would've stood more square and Moitai would have been useless
because Bj doesn't kick,
but then you'd be more open to punches.
So the way you're standing,
the way one of the boys standing that the antagonist to that,
that the antidote to that is that a kick?
So how could you stand that way?
Just swished away.
You're stunning and now it,
okay,
now you're more open to punches.
But that's adaptation.
That's what fighting is about.
Yeah.
It's rock,
paper,
scissors.
If I use rock,
I don't,
I don't outlaw paper.
I don't say everybody.
Hey,
nobody is allowed to use paper.
No,
but that's the antidote to what you're doing.
Yeah.
And when the ties fight,
they have that very light front leg which would prevent that front leg side kick
to the knee.
Exactly.
Cause they're always like very light.
So if you kicked their knee there,
it's just going to go backwards to stand.
That way they're standing that we had a cost,
yes.
Punches and also the cost.
They don't have the ability to use that movement,
that flattery.
Front leg movement.
The way that Wonderboy does to Wonderboy is the master of the front leg.
Like he,
he's the best at standing completely sidekick.
The,
when he fought Johnny Hendricks,
good example,
he threw a side kick to the body.
Hendrick stood there and then he went to roundhouse kicked Masta ace with the
same leg masterpiece and,
and Hendricks he could see was like fuck.
Like what does this guy do?
It was like thumb,
okay back.
Oh Shit.
Like he thought like,
yeah,
you got me with that,
but that's not a big deal.
And then pop,
he gets roundhouse kicked in the face.
That was a masterful performance.
Yeah.
It was one of his best for sure is incredible.
Well,
it just shows you the difference between a guy who is,
you know,
just trying to like kind of plot in with limited movement and a guy like wonder
boy who's just one of the most difficult guys to sort of pin down.
Yeah.
Incredible.
Yeah,
his style is very unique and I'm,
I'm a fascinated with him and I'm really fascinated right now with Michael Venom
page been watching.
Do you see as pro boxing fights?
No,
I didn't see right now he's a [inaudible].
I saw one.
Yeah,
he's a can crusher.
He's fighting these guys then they're setting them up for these,
yeah,
spectacular knockouts.
Right.
But it's still that blitz point karate style that Raymond Daniels has a lot of
these guys have in Raymond's obviously adapted very well for kickboxing.
I've changed with Raymond quite a bit.
He's a beast.
You've got to get them on the show and he says,
yeah,
I have to connect you to.
Okay.
He's amazing.
Yeah.
We had talked a little bit in the past about perhaps doing something on Twitter.
He knocks guys out in about 90 seconds on a regular basis.
And how does he do it?
He does it with the back kick.
He's the master at finding a place for the back kick.
You don't want to get hit with his back kick.
Like I know you got incredible backache.
I bet you some more powerful than his.
Okay.
But I'll tell you one thing.
He will fit that back kick everywhere,
everywhere.
And he'll do it in a way you won't see it coming.
And it's gonna hurt so much more.
But he rarely knucks guys out with his hands.
He does surprise guys with his hands every so often.
But that back kick you,
you don't want to be there.
Well he seems like he's getting better with his hands.
Yes.
Sands are improving,
but he trains a lot.
Yeah.
And trains a lot that go.
I'm sure.
I mean he's,
he's a,
he's still at it and he's what,
35 36 now I would say around that.
That one was it?
Uh,
what's his name?
I'm bang.
Was that the guy he knocked out with that touch front leg side kick and then
jumped on my God,
the spinning back kick to the face.
Woo Game Shits.
I believe he just jumps up top pop and they had some of the second kick.
Yeah,
double.
It's a standard.
Kik Is,
it is,
you know for,
for Redmond Dan,
he does it the best I've ever seen personally.
No,
no one better.
You know you to go back to like Rick the jet Rufus.
Oh Man.
You know what,
when he fought that the,
that really classic fight where he fought that tie fighter and he got his legs
chopped out and everybody was like,
Oh shit,
people really got it.
Understand the Vojtech Moy Tai,
but he hit that guy that same kick,
that front leg side kick him and spun in the air and hit him with the turning
side kick in the face.
Yeah.
Yeah Man,
I love watching that point.
Karate style,
that blitz style.
I love it.
I love watching that enter into MMA because I used to spar with a lot of those
guys and it's fucking hard to deal with those guys that are really good at that,
that that fast sprint at you blitz and when you do that and then you also have
takedown defense and Muay Thai skills and Jujitsu,
it's like,
fuck man,
that's so let's a lethal skill to have.
I love,
I love doing boxing.
Boy Ty karate,
taekwondo,
I love,
I love blending it all.
I believe all of your right here.
Boom.
It's just play that,
play that back again.
I mean come on man.
This is fucking crazy shit.
The way he does it too,
he just hops up,
touches you with the front leg pains and the second ones and look,
he looks down like he's in a fucking video game.
I mean that is crazy that this guy is pulling that off.
That was when he was in glory.
Look at this tap boom.
I mean,
come on man.
Well fuck does that.
And he does that all the time.
That's,
that's not,
that's not like a one off.
No,
no.
He could do that all day.
Yeah.
I mean there's a lot of those karate guys that have that skillset,
they can do like,
you know,
those breaking demonstrations with their hold up pads don't do three 60 wheel
kicks and brake pads and I mean there's,
there's some legitimate PR karate and traditional martial arts techniques that
are finding their way into MMA.
Absolutely.
You just have to know how to use it.
And the,
just because aquatic guy got beat up by a grappler doesn't mean all the karate
he's trained.
It's not good.
Exactly.
These loves,
that needs to learn how to grapple.
Exactly.
He needs to know how I stay on his feet and he's learning how to grapple and he
needs to learn to set that kickup in a way.
Because I think as if you're always fighting another karate guy and then you
fight a boxer,
the boxer,
his behavior is just different.
You have to get you,
it's like what we're saying before you have to get used to it and then all of a
sudden you saw the same movie a hundred
times.
You know how to deal with it.
You know,
it's like you're watching the same movie over and over again.
You start,
you start predicting what the scene is going to be.
You're not caught by surprise when you're caught by surprise,
you're done right.
You'd never done Jitsu before and I'm doing an armbar basic onboard.
You're getting caught with it.
You know?
That's why I believe you got to know everything out there,
but you've got to specialize.
Don't,
don't try to master everything.
Know everything.
Like,
I like to know Doris Triangle.
He'll hook.
Even though I'm not a necessarily a dark sky,
but I want to know everything about Doris.
I don't want to drill it all day long.
I just want to know about it.
Right.
Because when you're trying to put your Darson,
I know what you're trying to do.
I'm familiar with what you're going for.
I can break out of it.
You don't go for Darson.
I do.
But I mean,
I'm not,
I wouldn't say it's my best submission.
I do do the arses.
No doubt about it.
You don't have the longs arms.
Exactly.
Exact.
Do you ever try Japanese Necktie?
Uh,
yes,
I don't use them that much,
but I am,
I'm familiar with the solution for guys who don't have long arms.
I have short arms too.
But the Japanese necktie became a specialist at that when you really,
yeah,
you get that clamp over the time of the neck and then you drop down with the
left shoulder and you tuck the head into the forehead and you hook one of the
legs with your legs.
Yay.
Crack that neck.
So you're pushing in with your chest and then cracking that.
It's,
it comes,
it comes to,
it's a nasty,
nasty neck crank.
I love it.
It's just so good.
And it's also,
it's,
it's there a lot.
It's one of those techniques that people,
they're not aware of the danger that that one position,
you know,
there's a few guys that are really good at it and you know,
whenever you feel that arm going underneath your neck,
you're like,
fuck,
I gotta get Outta here.
Cause it's such an easy one to cinch up.
Doris is hard.
It's hard to synch to get all the way up.
Yeah.
Like,
I remember working with Marcello,
like I got to trade Marcello Garcia and a,
we're doing it just a one on one training session.
And uh,
he was telling me he doesn't like Doris when I was like,
he doesn't teach stars,
doesn't believe in Doris.
And I'm like,
but your arms are short.
You know,
if you have this monstrously long guy,
you won't tell them to do darks.
No,
no,
no.
Don't do the,
it's not good.
It's not good submission because your arms in the way.
I'm like,
dude,
there's some guys with w the most devastating.
Darcy's like you,
you don't want to be in their doors.
You know Tony Ferguson.
Yeah,
exactly.
He doesn't like leg locks.
Has No leg locks are no good.
But oh,
that's so crazy.
I imagine a Paul Harris Walks into your gym and you're like,
no,
don't do leg.
Like it's like,
dude,
that's his gay.
But he tapped out Rico Rodriguez with a heel hook.
I would die.
He would tell you it was there.
It's not a good submission.
It shouldn't have worked.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
He was telling me he doesn't like his guys to wrestle.
I'm like,
why?
when you fudge it shields you did a single leg and he took him down.
He was like,
he shouldn't have fell.
See Jake shields shouldn't have fell.
He said,
but I'm like,
you're wrestling is good.
He's like,
no,
no.
You shouldn't wrestle a wrestler at all.
What that was like.
I get,
I get what you're trying to say,
but there's a time of place while wrestle a wrestler.
When I see a good vulnerability.
Yeah.
And um,
I don't know.
He,
he's very,
I think he's changed over the years.
But when I was,
when I rolled with him,
he was like at the top.
You know,
you,
I wouldn't question him.
I wouldn't write the NL.
Who am I?
Who am I to tell him I don't agree.
You know?
Like he doesn't like Kimora.
He would tell me not too much muscle.
Right.
That's what he said to powerful.
It's powerful.
Yeah.
But when you look at his career,
he,
all of the things he doesn't like.
He's,
that's what he's been caught with.
Like a radio caught him with a Doris Shakuri Kamora yeah,
yeah,
that's right.
It didn't,
um,
who else caught him with the Darce and Braulio caught him once or twice.
Once I think.
Um,
oh.
Uh,
they'll caught them with Doris.
Doris work,
real good data.
They do like if you have the attributes,
they're great.
Yeah.
Why would he say he does a decent died?
That's so crazy.
I think he's got short arms and Fab.
It doesn't work.
He doesn't like a arm triangle.
It says no,
forget the arm triangle.
Yeah.
I'm like,
dude,
that's was Prince George's arm.
Triangle triangles and nasty.
This destructive.
What guy like George,
he's sits a crusher.
He's got long arms and he's heavy,
heavy,
puts that weight on you and knows how to control and squish.
Never let my arm get across my body because I know it's over.
There's two things you never want to give George Kimora because he'll rip your
arm off and too dark.
Uh,
a triangle triangle.
Yeah.
Catholic Hatami Yeah.
There's,
there's a Rafael Lovato.
He's,
he's got a nasty fucking arm trying,
you know,
he's competing in Beltour now I'm,
I'm always fascinated when I see like super,
super high level Jujitsu guys that enter into MMA because I'm like,
okay,
well for sure these guys who are used to just training MMA and trained,
they're not going to know what the fuck it's them.
When a guy like [inaudible] Gracie grabs him or like a guy like Damien Maia and
we've seen it time and time again,
there's,
there's a difference in the level.
And so the argument is always,
should you be just like,
what's the best way to be?
Is the best way to be an elite specialist at one particular thing,
like a Raymond Daniels or a Wonderboy?
Or is it to be a guy who can kind of do everything really well?
Like George?
So here's my perspective on that.
That's such a great question.
I mean that's the heart of training.
You could flood your system so that,
what does that mean?
When you flood your system,
you're giving your student too many things to master.
He's just really not good at anything.
Right.
Or you can bottleneck him.
You're giving him too few skills that people know what he does.
Like for instance,
like classic examples,
Chuck Liddell,
he went on a tear for a while,
but he's still the same guy and after a while the next generation,
they understood what he does.
They understood the pockets where you're safe,
where you're in danger,
like machine does.
A great example.
Early on he was such a mystery.
Now we're like,
okay,
we get what he does.
We've understood his patterns.
Patterns are huge and fighting and in life period.
Human beings or pattern detecting machines,
whether they know it or not,
whether they can verbalize it or not,
we are pattern detecting machines.
That's why I like sparring a lot because sparring,
I've had a thousand people throw a right hand at me.
When you throw your by hand my mind,
the subconscious is going to compare that right hind you're throwing to a
thousand different ranch hands I saw and it's going to say it looks matches this
one the most.
Again,
this is my narrative and this is what I see and this is personally been my
experience,
right?
When I train somebody who's new and you throw a punch at them,
they flinch,
why you've overwhelmed
them with information.
But after awhile they see a punch and they're relaxed and they see it in eaten
and it seems slow motion.
Cause at first it was too fast for them.
It's too much to compute.
So my students,
what I do is I give them a small amount of technique and when they get better I
give them a new technique.
So I want them to get a certain level of competence with that technique.
And my standard is it has to be instinctual.
If the technique is instinctual,
I've taught it to well meaning if you've done it live on the mat on a regular
basis,
you execute on a regular basis.
It's not for me not to give you another gym because if I don't give you another
gem,
I'm going to bottleneck your art.
You're going to become too predictable.
But if I give you a gem too early,
if I give you another technique too early,
I'm flooding your system.
I'm flooding the your game.
It's your game is just is diluted.
It's just two weeks.
So with George,
we're always reinventing George for the next fight.
We're always adding one new or two new gems depending how much time we have,
but there's always an x factor when you fight him.
He's not going to do the same patterns we did the last fight.
You could watch his tape.
That's why I told George,
why is it harder to be championed than to become champion?
Because when you're champion,
everybody's watching you in studying your patterns.
It's a matter of time before you're old news,
so you've got to reinvent yourself before the next fight.
That's why I didn't want him fighting three times a year.
I told me to fight twice a year and there were making comparative with Chuck.
I got a lot of heat for that.
They're like chuck fights three times a year.
George would fight three times a year.
We're like,
we'll see what,
how,
how hard careers go be.
I want George to fight twice a year because to reinvent them,
take six months,
we're going to do that twice a year.
That way he'll be champion longer.
I told him,
I saw him when he became champ.
He said,
I want you to be champion for 10 years.
It happens in boxing is gonna Happen to an MMA for the first time?
There's going to be a champion for 10 years.
I used to tell him that when,
when he first won the belt and he was like,
really?
How are we gonna do that?
You're going to read,
we're going to cycle.
We're going to do only training camps that last six months.
You can only really do a 20 cap every six months.
If you want to hit a new level,
it takes six months.
Every fight you got to be at a new level and you get to do something.
Nobody knows did they haven't seen it before.
How did you come up with these numbers?
What,
what made you decide?
Um,
I read once,
I read one very influential book called the New Power Program by Michael Colgan.
I don't know if you ever heard of it.
I have heard of the book.
I haven't read a book.
He says,
look,
there's two programs.
There's either,
he says,
look,
if you can do a training program shorter than six months,
you're either superman or your like.
He formulated the way he says,
I never met Superman.
A real training program is six months long,
so that's just always really influenced me.
I think his book was really,
really basic and this is one of the first books I read on training and it really
influenced me.
He taught,
he taught,
he teaches in the book periodization,
but he dumbs it down really,
really well.
So if you read to the pump,
pompous book on periodization is just too much at intellectual jargon.
It's hard for a regular Joe,
especially at the stage.
I was then to read the book and understand what he's trying to say and I,
it's like today I can understand it,
but Michael Colgan made it really simple for me and he's like,
look,
if you want to train and reach a new level,
it takes six months.
This is
the body's natural process.
So it would be like trying to,
uh,
you know,
plant a seed in there having an apple tree in three months.
Now he says,
no,
the apple tree grows at a certain rate.
So the human body does things at a certain rate.
There's no way around it.
You need stress,
you need recovery,
then you add up the adaptation.
Here's the,
the cycles you have to go through to reach a new level.
And it ends with a plyometric cycle.
Not Today.
I don't really use that system anymore because I found better ways over the
years.
It ends with a plyometric cycle.
Why does it end with a plan?
You have to hit the speed of your sport.
So for instance,
let's say you do a lot of back squatting.
Okay,
let's see.
Do backs one and your numbers on the back squat go up.
Do you think that's going to make you a better fighter?
No.
Why?
So?
Why do the squatty cause it'll make you stronger.
Okay.
But does it make you stronger on the field in the octagon?
It can make you stronger in certain positions in certain positions.
Yes.
Now I think my question was say it can make you stronger in certain positions if
you can apply that force over a certain time.
So power and strength of two different things.
Pop strength is can you live that bard weighs 500 pounds.
You can lift it.
Okay good.
Can you get that by off the ground and locked out in 1.5 seconds?
That's the question we want to ask for sports.
How fast can you apply the force?
That's power force over time.
A strength over time.
So when you want to shoot a double,
like you have to do it in the window.
So that's why the plyometric phases,
the last phase is very important that you need to take all that strength you
cultivated and translated to a level of speed.
So I need George to change level and explored in a fraction of a second.
So that's why I like things like sprinting,
track and field,
et cetera.
These are things done in a short period of time.
The ground contact,
the ground force reaction that the time you spent on the ground applying force
into the ground.
So when you want to apply force on a,
on a person,
you first have to apply the force in the ground and then I ground.
Then that reaction is applied into the,
into your opponent,
right?
So every action has an opposite.
Equal reaction.
How fast can you apply?
Apply that force into the ground.
Now squatters.
If I take you and I make you squat a slow squat down and up the I'm treating you
like a tow truck,
right?
Then I measure your vertical jump.
You're vertical jumps,
gonna have gone down after you've done six months of a squatting,
it's not going to have gone up.
Why?
Because you're training like a tow truck.
You're telling your body,
look,
I need to lift lots of money,
lots of heavyweights in a slow,
in a slow fashion.
However,
if I make you do plyometrics or I make you do Olympic lifting and Olympic
lifting is very fast,
it's 1.5 second contraction on the hamstring,
1.5 seconds.
And,
and there's a certain point where it's 0.5 seconds,
then I make you a test,
your vertical now your verticals gone up.
So there's an element of speed.
So Michael Colgan at the end of the program,
he does a a four week or three week phase of the calls.
It the link cycle where you're doing plyometrics is very important.
That's fascinating.
I've never heard it put that way.
And I like that thought.
I liked the thought process behind it.
I think there's a,
there's a lot of people that are using a lot of plyometric drills now.
Um,
and uh,
it's way more common when you see like training montage has of guys hopping over
hurdles.
But I really have to think that George was one of the first guys I ever saw do
that stuff.
I used to tell him,
do you want to treat it like a tow truck or do you want to train like a Ferrari?
Which one do you want to be [inaudible] if you look at Damien Maia,
he's like a tow truck.
Yeah,
he stiff.
Even when he throws a punch is a very stiff,
yeah.
Why?
Because years of gait training,
it's like,
yeah,
I've trained my body to make an isometric hold and now your built your body
behaves.
I symmetrically.
Why you asking you to do anything different?
I never ask my body to do something in practice that I don't want it to do on
fight night.
So I do believe squatting is important.
Squatting's important to develop a general strength.
So let's say for instance,
you're always doing plyometrics.
White,
you might have an overuse injury,
certain muscles not being activated.
You go on the squat rack,
you do a few squats and I believe you've got to do squats.
Um,
not,
not too heavy,
about 70% of your Max and do it fast.
You'll still get all the benefits.
What about lowering it Lauren,
and how do you lower it fast or do you lower it?
Lower it fast and up fast.
Really?
Yeah.
So for instance,
if Fred had field,
he's a probably said it best.
Okay?
He said he's the first man to officially squat a thousand pounds.
He said,
look,
throw a baseball,
throw a throw a paper,
you take a paper,
you can pull it up and you throw it,
it's too light for it to,
to to go anywhere.
You throw it really hard bit because it's so light.
That doesn't go anywhere.
Take a bowling ball or bowling balls too heavy,
throw it doesn't go anywhere.
You take a baseball,
that's the right amount of resistance.
It's the right amount of weight.
Now you're going to apply more force on that baseball.
You're gonna get more force out of it.
Why?
It's the,
it's in the goldilocks range.
So for instance,
let's say,
let's make it really simple.
Okay?
Let's see you way zero pounds.
I put you on a scale.
You weigh zero pounds.
You have a bar on your back.
The bar weighs 100 pounds.
Okay?
So we're looking at the scale.
Now the scale says 100 pounds,
the bars on your back.
Let's take away your weight just to make it really simple.
You go down and up.
The scale is going to read 101
that's the minimum amount of power you have to put into that,
that that scale for it to come up.
So when you go down the scale is going to say 100 100 as you come up,
it's going to say one on one.
For it to have a positive trajectory,
you have to apply 101 pounds upwards,
sorry,
downward.
And then reaction will be upwards.
If I put that weight on my back,
if I put 70 pounds,
if I think 70% of the weight and I go up and down really fast on the scale,
the scale is going to read 101 minimum for me to,
if I explode up really fast,
it's going to read 100100200 three now I got the benefits of a maximum
contraction,
let's say 100 pounds with a maximum you can lift,
but I don't have the weight of a hundred pounds on me.
You know,
somebody who,
who,
who really made this popular is a Louie Simmons.
He learned it from the Russians,
you know,
said.
Have you had him on your show?
Yes.
He's a brilliant trainer.
He's fascinating.
He's a brilliant human being too.
He's out of his mind.
We,
we interviewed an Hermes in his gym.
Really?
Yeah.
And uh,
Columbus,
it was great.
But he's a genius when it comes to lifting.
Yeah,
he's a genius.
He knows what he's talking about.
He read super training.
I also read super training.
It's super training is about lowering the rates to the right amount and doing a
plyometric with it.
You get the same benefits is using maximum weight,
but you don't get the side effects,
the soreness,
the injury,
the red lining.
You don't get anything out of that.
So the Russians found a great way to apply maximum force on the bar,
but they also get speed.
They're not training like tow trucks to training like Ferrari's.
That's actually where I got the term from Louie Simmons.
He really clarified it for me.
Made it really simple.
So like what kind of like say if you could bench press a 315 pounds,
what would you use?
You use between 65 to 80% of that weight and it's just real quick,
boom,
boom.
You'll get the same amount of resistance if you do it quickly as if you had the
maximum weight on it.
So he doesn't use maximum weight except for once a week.
And the reason why he explains it,
he says,
look,
you have proprioceptors in your system.
Proprioceptors is like,
it's what tells you if your arm is up or down.
If your arm is bent to your chest,
if you are,
if you,
if I close your eyes and I lift your arm,
you'd be like,
you're lifted my arm.
Oh,
how do you know that?
Appropriate sectors?
He says,
if you,
if you put on a map,
let's say you,
let's say you're working with um,
75 pounds and your maximum is a hundred.
When you go to lift that day and on the competition date,
when you get a hundred on your bones,
your buddy's going to be like,
Hey,
I've never felt that amount of weight.
This is Arthur.
Kinetic reflects,
shut the muscles down.
We've never felt that weight.
This is the narrative that he gives us.
He says,
because you've never felt that weight,
your body's going to,
it's not going to allow you,
there's a safety mechanism in your body.
It says,
look,
this is,
this isn't,
we're not used to this.
Let's not take a chance.
And he says,
if you get your body used to that,
the Ortho kinetic reflex will,
will quiet down and allow you to lift.
There's,
there's an inner mechanism,
the safety mechanism in the human body.
So he says to bypass that,
we do heavyweights once a week to two to numb that reflex.
So,
but the majority of the work is done with lightened,
sorry,
lighter and fast.
75%,
let's say.
What do you think of like Pavel Tot Selenis principles by the strong first
principles of the,
like say if you could do 10 reps of something you don't do 10,
you do five.
Exactly right.
How'd you percent?
I've read all of [inaudible] works.
Almost all of them.
He's brilliant trainer that I agree with that 100% outside of competition.
Let's explain it to people.
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
yeah,
let me,
uh,
okay.
So let's say for instance,
let's say,
you know,
I'm a big believer never being sore.
You should train the next day she'd wake up feeling good.
Okay?
And I'll why,
how's that possible?
Well,
because look,
if if,
okay,
that's great.
That's a great example.
Let's say,
um,
let's see your energy levels as talking about fit people,
by the way,
right?
Every human being,
every cell guys never worked out before.
First Day first,
they never call.
Is it possible to work out and not be so no problem.
Here we go.
So let's say there's something called cr rate of perceived exertion.
Okay?
So let's say I make you do pull ups and let's say the maximum on of pull ups you
can do the maximum out of bill is 10.
Let's keep a nice round number at 11 you couldn't do 11.
If I put a pointed a gun at you,
you couldn't do 11.
Should I make you do 10 pull ups on our workout?
Now I'm going to make you do five.
Why?
Because I'm setting you up to work the next day.
The next day we're going to do five and the next day we're going to do another
five and then we're going to six.
When six is really easy,
we're going to do seven y if you count,
if the,
if you did 10 pull ups on Monday,
you're going to be sore till Thursday.
What's,
it's really your Max.
So Thursday you've only done 10 pull ups from Monday to Thursday.
Volume done,
10 pull ups.
Me,
I've been doing five pull ups every day,
so I'm at 20 pull ups already.
25 pullups.
I have more volume than you now.
If you add up at the end of the year,
who trained?
The more I've trained way more than you.
So let's say I go to Jitsu practice.
I'm doing Jujitsu every single day.
Three rounds,
five days a week.
That's 15 rounds.
You go in twice a week,
but you kill yourself.
You do five rounds each day you kill,
you push yourself.
Those last two rounds,
you burn yourself out.
I still did 15 you're at 10 at the end of the year.
I've done countless rounds more than I am.
I may have had at so much more training than you.
So how much training can we pack in in the week?
That's the real question.
How much volume can you expose your athlete too?
So I always tell people look energy as,
sorry,
exercise can produce energy.
So let's say I'm feeling like a seven out of 10 10 being I'm really like
energized one.
I was like really lethargic,
feeling like I need to lay down and seven I'm feeling good.
Okay.
If I get up and I do a right amount of exercise,
the right amount,
I can feel like an 8.5 exercise can give me a tonic effect,
like drinking this coffee.
So let's say I just do some jumping jacks.
It hit the back for a couple of rounds.
I'm feeling good.
Once you get that high,
shut it down.
Don't go into the phase where your body's beat up,
tight,
broken up.
Don't redline the body.
That's only for training camps for P for a small period of time.
Why?
Because you get a little bit more from the system,
but in the long run you get less.
In the long run,
you've tax the system.
So if you do that regularly,
by the time you actually get good,
you'll be broken up.
Mm.
That's why I do a lot of flow.
And have you ever,
have you ever heard of a Mihai send me high as a,
a flow?
No.
Okay.
So you can you,
can you Jamie,
can you look up a flowchart?
It'd be so much simpler.
Like just put in flow a flow in the workplace,
a flow chart.
This is such,
this is pure genius.
This guy is pure genius.
Basically.
He went and he,
uh,
he coined the term flow.
So like when you're in a state of flow,
we've all been in a state of flow.
The number one
way to know that you're in a state of flow.
As time flies by,
I'm sure some somebody you've done podcasts and you're like,
what was it,
three hours already?
It was,
it was a great podcast.
You know,
the one where you have the worst guest or you're,
you're having the worst workout.
It feels like every minute is an hour.
That's a bad,
you're not in a state of Florida.
State of flow is you're having the right amount of difficulty,
but it's not so difficult that you go into stress and it's not so easy that
you're bored.
It's the right amount of challenge.
So let's see it as simple as playing it like tetris.
If I put you on a,
if I put you on a level that's too high,
you can be like you're going to play for five minutes and be like,
I'm done.
I put you on a level two easy.
You're going to be like,
this is boring.
If I put you on the right amount of level,
you see that as the flow channel.
So if the challenge is too high,
you'll meet anxiety.
If it's too low,
your border.
When I go in the practice room,
I'm trying to create flow.
I'm having fun at training should be addictive.
Imagine training was addictive.
Everybody would train everybody to be fit,
but people always go into anxiety.
They go and they kill.
They're slammed their body.
Then I have to convince you to do it again three days later,
two days later,
and you're like,
dude,
the mental energy is going to take me to get there.
Like it shouldn't be.
It should be.
Training should be a pulling force.
It should be pulling you.
You want to go training.
If you don't want to go train it,
it's not fun.
If it's not fun,
you're not gonna do a lot of it.
And if you're not going to do a lot of it,
you're never going to reach mastery.
So how do I make it pleasurable?
How to make it fun?
I have to be in a flow state and you can get into a flow state in almost
anything.
But when you're out of that flow state,
cut it.
We're going to get further.
We're going to do more training if we cut it today and come back in tomorrow.
Cause I'm a big believer in consistency over intensity.
Intensity should be done one in a once in a while because by nature,
intensity can only be done once in a while.
If you're going hard every day,
you're not really going hard every day.
You can't go your Max everyday.
There's a,
there's a,
there's a cost to going to your Max.
Can you sprint every single day and you cannot sprint every single day.
It's ludicrous.
You could sprint once or twice a week.
The best sprinters in the world is print once or twice a week.
Nobody's sprints every day because intensity by nature entails that you need to
take a break because if you don't need to take a break,
you didn't really go to your maximum intensity.
If you lift your maximum lift,
the maximum amount of reps you can,
the maximum weight you can lift.
If you do two reps that was in your Max,
because if it was you wouldn't have have a second revenue.
Understand what would have to give you a break for you have a second rep.
So we didn't find your true Max.
Right?
Intensity maximum effort entails you have to stop because it's the maximum.
There was no more reserves.
There are no more reserve.
So what do you think about people that they'd say,
there's no such news overturning.
Here's the John Denver,
our narrative and that I'll add.
And he said he coins it really,
really well.
He says,
look,
it's under arrest.
So he says,
look,
you can overtrain if you didn't give your body the rest later.
Yeah.
But he says,
look,
no matter how hard I push in practice,
if I didn't kill myself,
I can rest from it.
Then recover and have super comp compensation.
I agree with that.
Some guys have made great strides with just mental fortitude and mental
strength.
Overtrained the shit out of themselves.
Okay,
but can I ask you this?
Yes.
They were successful.
Yeah.
But their body's breakdown,
right?
But they could,
could they have been better if they used flow?
Exactly as good as I say,
Dan Gable for exempt,
right?
Example,
like w Dan Gable essentially was done in his twenties right?
In terms of like,
his body's broken down.
Exactly.
Knee replacements,
hip replacements,
that kind of deal.
Let me ask you this.
Who Wins more often?
Russians or American wrestlers rations.
Every time an American wrestler wins.
He's like some pro prodigy.
He's rare.
It's rare.
It does happen,
but it's rarely is a technical master,
right?
However,
you have these Russian guys that win gold medals,
you've never heard of them and they're like Michael Jordan's of the sport.
There's just so many of them.
They train long consistent practices.
Whereas in America we do Monday,
Wednesday,
Friday,
hard,
we kill it and then you rest use your Thursday.
The Eastern Block had a totally different understanding there like it's volume,
volume,
volume near the fight,
short and intense.
Only near the the competition phase,
but before that it's the maximum amount of volume.
You can imagine me and you were or where to athletes a,
and B,
your a and B,
you're training Jujitsu three times a week.
Really,
really hard.
You're going all out.
I'm training Jiu Jitsu every single day.
My average practice is two hours.
Your average practice is two hours,
but when you go in,
you kill it like you,
you go,
you go with all the black belts and you kill it.
At the end of the year.
I'm averaging three practices are two practices more than you.
So I've had a hundred practices more than you by the end of the year,
104 practice.
Let's give two weeks for vacation.
Hundred practices more than you to 100 hours more than you had been training.
When we roll,
your intensity that you put on the mat is going to be irrelevant.
Why?
Cause I've also tasted that intensity periodically.
It's not that much of a factor.
Now when you go super aggressive on me,
when you talk me aggressively,
I have felt that I know how to deal with it.
Plus I have an extra hundred hours on you 200 hours so I'm going to mangle you.
You know what I'm saying?
The volume is far more important than the intensity.
The intensity by nature is neat,
is neat to be done periodically.
If you do everyday it's light intensity.
So how the Russians is,
how do they structure their training?
They're more playful,
you know,
they kind of like,
they kind of warm up,
they kind of float all.
They kind of like,
they do a lot of technique,
high emphasis on technique.
Now a lot of people hearing this are gonna be like,
well,
the Russians also are funded by their government.
Their government supports them a lot more than maybe an American,
a wrestler.
Okay.
I agree with that.
There are many factors,
however,
we can't deny that they're technically hates it,
the word superior,
but they're technically more advanced.
Technically when it comes to wrestling,
they have a more of a flow understanding.
They play around in it and it,
and,
and the practice gets more and more intense,
more and more intense.
Until you see them going really,
really hard.
They're going live,
you know,
they're going to really,
really rough,
but they were playing to have a more playful attitude.
Look at the Cubans.
You ever see Cubans aspiring,
they're like 50 guys in the room.
They're just touch boring.
There's no head gear.
There's no mat on the floor.
They're literally sparring on concrete.
You think they're really trying to drop each other?
They're on concrete.
I mean,
the Cubans are the top boxers.
They're consistently win gold medals.
But in practice from their playful,
nobody gets hurt.
Like you're saying the ties,
ties or just if,
if you go in there and you,
and you kick a tire really hard,
he won't spar with you anymore.
He was like,
this guy's tools to amateur.
Hmm.
There's a time and place for intensity.
I'm not anti intensity.
I think that there's a time and place like Angelo Dundee was probably arguably
the greatest boxing trainer in history.
He says,
look,
fighting's for fight night in practice,
it's only
practice.
George Saint Pierre has that attitude and I think that's why he's so good and so
healthy today.
You know,
because he never hurts a sparring partners.
People line up to one a spar with him.
It's a joy to spar with them.
Yeah.
I,
I love this idea and I'd love this approach.
I think that,
um,
we,
we have this attitude that you have to be tough and we have this attitude that
you have to work hard.
And uh,
I mean,
I've fallen prey to that many,
many times in my life.
Or you just gotta be tougher.
You got to work out harder.
You got to push harder,
but when I read Pavel stuff,
one of the first things that struck me is like,
well yeah,
of course.
If you just do five reps every day and then you won't be sore,
you could do it more often and then your body,
like you get farmer strength.
Exactly where it's farmer strength come from farmers.
They're not going to exhaustion.
Oh you know,
they're not throwing hail big bales,
Hay Bales to the point where you know they literally,
they're heaving and they'll put their hands and knees and like come on five
more.
You should never be solar.
If you're sore,
you over did it.
Whoa.
Cause I can't train the next day.
If I'm sore,
I open the wound every time I work out.
Then with that I said,
I've overdone it.
Worked out to you.
They have,
you may have,
you got to,
there's a lot of people listening to this right now.
I'll wait a minute.
How the fuck make your workouts a seven out of 10 and do them every day?
You're going to get far more training hours.
You're going to spike your mat.
You're going to spike your metabolism far more often,
your energy levels,
your mood is going to be far more,
uh,
up and,
and training is going to be more addictive.
Now,
what kind of training do you do at this stage?
Like you're not competing,
but you're constantly in their sparring with guys who are professionals and
you're constantly training them.
Like what kind of stuff do you do?
Um,
I do Jujitsu,
wrestling,
Moitai and a small amount of conditioning.
After practice I'll do,
I,
I'm too bored.
I find jumping hurdles and throwing it like we're doing the weights and stuff.
Me Personally,
I don't find that as enjoy.
I don't have to take that much enjoyment of it.
I can do five to 20 minutes in a practice.
Isn't that because barring is just so fun,
so much fun.
I'm in a flow state.
We're having fun.
You know,
we're wrestling with I think condition.
You can't get away with it.
You need it.
He needed,
and we've got to talk about what George was saying on your podcast that he
doesn't do strength and conditioning and there's,
there's a language issue there.
It doesn't think and what we gotta talk about that because we've done tremendous
amounts of strength and conditioning.
Me and George like tremendous like barrels full.
Okay.
And uh,
but he has a different definition.
He,
there's a misunderstanding.
Okay.
So I really want to clarify that,
but me personally,
if we roll for an hour for me to pass like this,
cause it's so fun.
It's so fun.
We're having a good time.
I'm fascinated.
Like you grabbed it like this.
I like,
I'm always learning new things,
right?
Um,
to the swing a kettle bell to do push ups,
pull ups.
I can only do that for a finite amount of time.
So I'll put a timer,
three rounds,
two minutes and I'm doing it and I bite the bullet and I do it.
That keeps me healthy.
But I don't go in practice to just do that.
That I never do.
It's always after my workout.
After I do Jujitsu.
You,
you'll never have a day where you say,
today I'm going to do Olympic lifting.
No,
I don't think Muhammad Ali ever done Mohammed Ali,
never
he box and they needed this.
Conditioning me.
Whether it does this conditioning,
then he boxes.
The aid always came together.
Why?
When I go to the gym,
I'm going to go to have fun,
I'm going to go wrestle,
I'm going to go box,
I'm going to have a blast and I'm going to grab the kettle bell.
I'm going to do a few presses,
I'm going to do a few Turkish getups and I'm done because I need to have some
general fitness.
You have general fitness,
then you have specific fitness.
Specific fitness is to get better at my sport.
General fitness to keep me healthy,
strong and allow me to reach new levels of athleticism that later in longterm
can translate to my sport later.
But if you just do your sport,
in my opinion,
your system's going to break down,
your back's gonna break down,
your knees going to break down,
your shoulders going to break down.
You need to stimulate certain muscles that are not getting stimulation in your
specific sport.
You create atrophy and certain muscles cause you're not using them.
Really I need to work my stabilizers.
I need to swing the Kettlebell,
I need to squat,
I need to do certain exercises.
Like what are the,
what are their standard course?
Kettle bells for.
Is that like triple extension is number one.
So any type of squatting maneuver.
I don't particularly use the squat.
I like to use extension.
Triple extension.
So your knee,
hip and ankle are bending also like a squat,
your knee,
hip and ankle or Benny.
I like to jump.
I like to throw the Med ball a lot against the wall.
I like to do a hurdles.
I can do box jumps.
I like to very low impact parametrics.
I like sprinting.
Sprinting is huge.
You ever do the be test?
What's that?
Oh you got,
you got the space for the beep test here.
You've got to implement.
What it does is the best way to do cardio.
You ever hear the,
the soccer players uses a lot.
It's a beat,
right?
You run,
you beep and then it beeps back.
And the faster the beeps go,
the faster you have to run.
Ah,
that's really amazing because what I do is I set a timer for five minutes.
I put it on a high pace,
like I'll put a 10 or 11 and I'll just shuttle back and forth.
And it keeps,
it tells you how fast to run to beat test.
And some days I'll feel really good.
I'll do 11 cause I know how fast I have to run to keep up with the beats and
that just,
it's amazing for cardio.
It's short,
sweet,
painless,
and it's,
it's very,
uh,
it translates very well to sports.
Do you do to Bottas do you ever do tabata bottles are good?
Yeah,
I think tomatoes are good.
If they're done well,
they're good.
But again,
you have to do it in a way it doesn't create soreness cause Tabata can create
soreness.
You have to be very,
I wouldn't do Tabata Kettlebell swing,
that'll,
that'll cook my,
my hamstrings.
I'll probably do like hurdle jump.
Like you take a small hurdle hurdle over it for 20 seconds.
Now,
what you're saying though,
like there's gotta be a bunch of crossfit people out there right now that a
screaming into their phones,
they're wrong.
All the respect,
the wrong.
I can say all due respect with all the respect,
Let me tell you why.
Okay.
And then look,
if you like crossfit,
do with whatever motivates you to do it.
Okay,
cross its problem is it's fatigue seeking.
Yes.
It says,
look,
go out there and burn yourself out.
That's totally wrong.
They're not building any skill.
Try to show me a guy who a champion of crossfit champion and digital they got
would need two lifetimes to read.
Which mastery in both of those.
Why?
Because my crossfit workout is going to tax me so much.
I cannot learn armbar sweep,
triangle choke,
double leg,
take down under hook might have tax my whole system.
My system is in recovery.
When your systems in recovery,
what can you do
but rest in the sun.
Okay.
Half a Mendez.
Do you think half a Mendez,
one of the,
arguably the greatest pound for pound,
one of the greatest profit pounds Jiu Jitsu guys in the world.
Do you think he's got a great,
uh,
a crossfit workout that he's really mastered?
He's really good.
I do think it has a great back squat.
Do you think he's a great dead lifter?
It doesn't look like it.
No,
he doesn't believe me.
You think we think,
uh,
Gordon Ryan,
he's a great,
uh,
Olympic lifter.
No,
they,
they're,
they're always going to be at an amateur level.
And that in the fitness world,
why?
Because if they were experts,
they would have taken so much from,
there's Jujitsu,
like,
look at Georgia.
Does gymnastics.
Okay.
I,
and I'm the one who quite twisted his arm a little to put them in gymnastics.
Why?
Uh,
because I thought it would,
it would give them a tremendous benefit because,
uh,
of,
the amount of,
first of all,
they use a lot of body weight,
so it doesn't cost us anything neurologically.
Bodyweight exercises are very easy to recover from.
Bodyweight exercises are very easy on the nervous system.
They use leverage instead of weights plus the stabilizers.
Strength is unbelievable.
So of course I want a coordination.
I felt George was a little bit stiff,
mechanical and the tumbling makes you more fluid.
I think I,
I thought it would create more efficiency this way.
So we get them there and there's,
there's difficulties.
Okay.
From eight to F,
we're still at a and B and he'll always be at a,
and B,
maybe he'll touch,
see it in his career,
but he'll never get to f.
You'd have to start really young and you'd have to do it full time.
You know,
imagine somebody trying to get good at Jujitsu,
doing it part time.
He'll never get good.
He'll do,
he'll be so,
so he'll reach such a level.
Crossfit is to fatigue seeking for an MMA fighter.
Now if crossfitters followed,
uh,
if the,
if they just follow that 70% rule,
they can periodically went to their max periodically as opposed to every single
workout.
Go total the out.
I bet you their top top guys don't go all out every day.
I bet you a few.
If you watch with their top guys,
do they taper off the work that they make the workout between 70 and 85% of
their true Max and they work volume and then closer to competition,
they go hire an intensity.
I guarantee you that's what the best crossfitters do.
There's no way that the guy who goes balls out every day is going to add up as
much workout and as much training time as the guy who was going 70 to 85% of his
Max.
There's just no way.
But when they do those classes,
like say they do a crossfit class,
and I'm speaking out of ignorance,
honestly,
because I only watch them on video.
I've never done it across the class,
but it seems to me they're competing against each other.
Yeah,
they're going all out trying to set a PR every class.
that's ridiculous.
All the respect.
I mean it's just,
it doesn't make any sense,
but why is it so popular?
Because people think that's right because why?
Because when you watch a prime time or a fight,
the guys at the peak,
he's going at the,
he's at a point in his career in his foot,
in his training camp where he's at the high end of intensity,
so people are always watching the last part of your camp,
the part where you're peaking and then you're going to go taper off or 10 15
days.
They don't see that part and they don't see the month before where you ramped up
to that level.
They just see the last two,
three weeks where it's the last few sparrings and we're mimicking fight speed to
the maximum as we can.
We're fruiting with danger here.
We're only doing it a little bit,
but that's the part everybody's watching,
so they think,
oh,
if you want to become a really good,
you have to flirt with danger every day.
If that's what their workouts are.
If you see George train throughout the year,
you'd be like,
hey,
that wasn't so intense.
That wasn't so intense.
There's another really mellow practice.
I remember when I was younger,
I was training at the ground brothers,
Jim and I would see Otis grant,
you know,
he's a world champion boxer.
He says everybody knew him in Canada because he's a man and he was training
really relaxed and I was like,
dude,
I'm training harder than him.
But he's,
that's his millionth workout.
There was my 10th you know,
he's doing in the long run,
he's added way more years of training.
So that's when I started to understand that the champion,
the best guy,
he's training for the long run.
It's far more intelligent.
He's getting far more workouts in than me that's burned out in the next day.
I need a rest.
Right?
Yeah.
So it's,
it's consistency over intensity.
Intensity entails you need to take a break because there's no way around it.
So if you're a young person listening to this and you're got a coach that's
trying to burn you out every day,
the fuck do you do?
I'm
going to the gym and go,
you know what?
I was listening to frost the hobby the other day.
And for us saying,
you're a retard.
Here's my,
here's my,
uh,
you know,
when I roll with the guys,
I think they feel when I grabbed them,
I'm grabbing them gently and they realize it and I'll let them,
like,
I like guys pass my guard.
Like I'll just go ahead and start second tool and I'll just get,
they'll get the message that we're just kinda playing around.
Right.
And then later when we were going more intense,
you know,
they'll feel it,
they'll feel the intensity.
But I don't always roll heart.
Like if you see me rolling,
like I usually will roll with blue belts and pro ball swipe.
Does there need to warm up?
I need three,
four rounds of warmup,
right?
I don't want to even have a tight shoulder or tight hamstring.
I don't want anything type of course.
So I warm up with them.
Really good one.
I'm really warm.
Then I go in at a wrestle,
I like to go rest.
I extend,
okay,
who wants to wrestle?
Know what's cool because I'm really warm than I can wrestle.
I could hit the ground well,
but you're in a position where you can sort of determine and dictate what kind
of exercises you do.
Right.
But if you were,
the question was like if you were a young person and you're entering into an MMA
gym and the instructor,
those to be kind is a meathead,
right?
Which there's a lot of them out there.
There is,
yeah.
What do you do?
A,
you might have to take a few beatings as white belt,
you might like,
I mean,
I grind my gears when I was younger,
but as you get older and more skilled now you can take the VIP lane,
you know,
now's the time,
you've got the skill and you've got the knowledge,
but early on you have less miles on you,
so it's,
you'll survive more,
more of a beating.
You ever see those?
There's a lot of Jujitsu classes where they go through an extremely rigorous
conditioning routine before they ever do any training.
And I've always disagreed with that and I agree totally.
Right.
Yeah.
I feel like show me one world champion that did it that way.
Wow.
I Dunno.
Maybe.
Maybe it's possible that they did.
Who?
I don't know.
I don't know who did what.
I've trained with a lot of the greatest Jujitsu guys in the world and they're
all warm up a technique.
Yeah,
all of them.
Do you think Ryan Hall gets up and does the burpees before practice?
You think he goes in,
he runs five miles and he does weights.
I know that like a lot of the old school guys,
they were,
they were into that like a,
isn't half Gracie famous for his,
uh,
those conditioning drills?
They do.
I don't know,
but he never went to like,
uh,
you know,
I mean he,
he was in a time and place where very few people knew Jujitsu.
Right now we're in where the secret's out.
Who are the top guys?
What are they doing?
Yeah.
I feel like there's also a thing where people want to be really tired from
workouts.
They feel like they're getting a great workout in if you beat them down.
Yeah.
I agree with that.
There's,
there's,
there's a debt,
a disconnect.
It was like,
I want to feel paid,
punish me.
Yeah.
You're your retarding growth though.
You know like people don't like that word retard anymore but because you know
they think you're talking about someone with a disease but the,
the real term of being of retarding you are,
you're slowing down growth and that's really what retarded action is.
Like you're,
you,
you have an issue in that the way you're approaching things is uniquely damaging
to your ultimate goal of progress.
And I agree.
It's so common.
If someone right now is listening,
he is mine.
It's blog is my better going to class and they know that they're going to happen
to all these crazy burpees and all this crazy shit before class.
It's so fucking comment.
ICARUS,
you flight to close to the sun.
What happens to you?
You get burned by this.
His stay in the middle there in the middle.
If you get to do those conditioning exercises kind of half asam halfass and a
bit,
yeah,
you permission.
That's why I like,
I like to make conditioning after.
Yeah.
Because my body is warm and I don't need,
cause the thing is look,
when you do conditioning,
before you weaken your stabilizers,
the prime mover,
the Ma,
the muscles in your body that are prime movers have more interest than your
stabilizers.
So few weekend the stabilizers,
your joint is less stable while you're rolling.
Yes.
The element of fatigue can put your joints in danger.
That's why I only do cause when you're,
when you're,
when you're doing exercises,
you're in control.
You're not in a live role with somebody trying to tug on your arm.
Right.
So I need maximum strength when somebody is trying to tug on my arm in case I'm
in a bad position,
I need to make sure that I have,
my strength levels are there to protect my joints.
Joint protect.
Joint protection is huge.
You need to make sure your joints are healthy.
It's huge.
What what,
what kind of exercises do you do to make sure your joints are protected?
Well I do the supple leopard,
I do a lot of mobility work and I do low impact plyometrics,
low impact.
So,
for instance,
that's why I like the Med ball.
Throwing the Med ball against the wall.
I like to do steps.
You know like you have a block,
like a 12 inch block and like to jump,
like do steps over a back and forth.
So you kind of jumped up in the air,
but she never leave the ground because the block is also high.
So you never get the negative contraction.
You never get the impact of hitting the ground.
Alec sprinting.
I like club.
Explain that.
How do you not getting the negative?
So let's say for instance there's,
this is a block and this is my feet right here,
right?
So I'm like this,
I'll jump like I saw,
I'll jump.
Okay,
so you touched the block.
I've touching the block so I'm never,
when I,
when I jumped off the ground,
I'm landing on the block so I'm always,
I'm stepping down,
jumping up,
stepping down,
jumping up.
I say,
so I'm always exploding up but landing on a block softly because it's,
it's when you jump up,
it's the landing that kills your joints.
If I put up a a 50 inch box,
Emma,
you jump up the landings in be very soft.
If I tell you jump over a hurdle now you're in midair and you're crushing down
towards the ground and you land,
you got to absorb that shock.
But that's why I like like hill sprints.
Hill sprints are great because your foot never leaves the ground even though
you're exploding upwards that the ground is coming up with you.
So it's a very soft landing.
The soft landing is key.
Yeah,
no,
that makes a lot of sense.
That makes a lot of sense.
But what about hitting bag then?
It's the best.
Cardio is the best.
I do a lot of Dutch Joe for cardio.
Dutch drills with Israel.
Left Hook,
cry,
kick,
right hand,
left kick,
three minutes,
just bad bup,
bup,
bup home.
Somebody they do three punch combo to punch Combo and it finished with a
kickboard double kick and I just spiked my heart rate that way.
I'm developing my skill,
developing my cardio.
I get very lean when I do that and uh,
I feel great.
I feel my energy levels are up and say it's better than doing bike or running
personally cause I'm developing my skill and I'm also spiking my heart rate.
A dage drill can be very intense on the heart rate.
It's low impact and it's a plow metrics.
Everything I need.
Yeah.
Do you,
what?
What wait heavy bag do you use?
I use the fair text.
The giant pole bag,
they call it like a big,
big giant bag of touches the ground.
So when I kick it it doesn't move.
Father's heavy as fuck.
It's like a 300 pound bag,
right?
Yeah.
Why do you like that one?
Because when it kick it,
the bag doesn't swing so I don't have to reset so I can keep that pace really
high.
So I'm going pop,
pop,
pop.
I know you're hitting it full blast or you just saw them.
As I get warmed up,
I hit harder and harder til I'm full blast so I might start really relaxed,
kicking low to the leg.
Then as the work gets warmer and warmer and hotter and hotter,
I'm sweating my start kicking to the head.
Hmm.
Everything is gradual warmup,
you know?
And when I've had enough,
I stopped like I'm not gonna make myself sick because I'm working out tomorrow
again right now.
What about stretching?
Stretching,
I like,
but I prefer mobility.
So mobility is the element of stretching your muscle,
but also creating motion.
The joint has to be in a type of rotation in the route.
Why?
Because you're creating Sylvan synovial fluid to the joint.
The joint is really more important to me than the muscle because the muscle
rejuvenates itself.
The joint doesn't,
it does let us lesser degree,
so I got to always be oiling up the joints.
This is very important to me.
Very important.
Now when you say like mobility,
like what do you do like for your hamstrings and things like that?
If you're trying to stretch them out and also do mobility.
So let's say I stretch out my leg,
I'll be just kind of bending at the hit in and out.
I won't just leave it out there static.
There has to be a type of motion.
I said it's very important because when I'm wrestling or I'm doing Jiu Jitsu,
my legs out there and I'm creating motion,
I have to move.
I'm not just putting it out there.
Right.
There's always a type of movement because when I stretch my leg out to stop you
from passing the guard,
I'm going to be moving my body at the same time.
So that's mobility.
It's different.
Some stretching,
mobility.
There is a stretch element and mobility,
but it's stretching.
There's no mobility element.
Now what about yoga?
I think yoga is good for relaxation and the range of motion.
I think it's very good.
I just don't personally have the time and energy for it because I'm always in
the gym.
So for me to find time for yoga,
it's just a little bit difficult,
but I think it does allow for a great range of motion and relaxation and
centering.
If you have the time in your schedule.
It's good.
I just personally with three kids and then my,
everything that I do,
I just,
I'm in the gym already too much.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
I just wonder like for fighters,
I mean I'm hearing more and more fighters incorporate yoga into the training
sessions to just try to create more balance and,
and also stability,
joint stability in particular because you're holding these static positions for
long periods of time valance and,
and,
and it's a brilliant art your core as well.
Yeah,
it's a brilliant art.
If you can have the time and energy to do it,
it's great.
Now what about nutrition?
Nutrition is huge.
What do you,
how do you eat?
Uh,
right now I just finished Ramadan so I've been eating a lot of processed foods.
I've had like Robin,
Don's like the,
with the time of the year where I gained a lot of weight because normally
throughout the year I ate very little processed foods.
I eat natural foods.
But during Ramadan,
because I was such a small window to eat,
to fit my calories in and I'm very busy all year round,
I'm always,
I'm always have projects so we're not fights traveling.
I eat processed foods when I eat processed foods out.
Why process?
Because there's more calories in them.
You know,
if I got,
if I got to get my,
if I'm going to go the whole day after no water,
no food,
I need to have eaten a certain amount of,
of,
of calories in the night.
So if I eat whole,
if I eat a salad and then some fruits,
um,
I'm going to be,
I'm going to be at zero byte,
afternoon ride in a hot gym with a bunch of guys.
We need to drill and work and I'm sweating in the gym just standing there and
haven't even started yet.
I'm sweating.
I got to hold pads.
I've got to wrestle this guy.
This guy needs these positions like I'm,
I'm working and at zero.
So I need that,
that,
that density of foods that I get from,
uh,
um,
processed foods.
But if I take a serious loss in energy and,
and,
and I get,
I got to gain weight for sure.
No doubt about it.
Wow.
Salsas foods is the worst for Ramadan,
for the month in the moment you wake up until the sun goes down.
You can't have any food,
any water.
No.
From the Sunrise Sunrise.
So you wake up before sunrise,
right?
You will eat.
Most people do that by the,
by the middle,
by midway of Ramadan.
I stopped doing that because I just can't get up anymore.
I just can't wake up.
My buddy is a bit of a wreck.
So butts from sunrise
to sunset,
you're not consuming anything.
No food,
no water.
If you can have water,
it will be easy.
Like I don't people who do water fast,
I've done waterfowl.
It's quite easy.
You have the energy,
but when you cut the water,
it's,
it's a,
it becomes a problem.
Especially if you're in a hot gym and you just sweating standing there.
Yeah,
no,
it's in the summer run nuns in the summer.
It's very humid in Canada and it's hot,
very hot.
So I have to be very careful and that's why at night,
even just to resist eating processed foods is too difficult.
You gotta eat.
So do you have a specific calorie number that you try to hit?
Uh,
no.
Not really.
Honestly,
no.
I just kind of foods you're eating.
When you say process,
whatever my mom or wife is going to make and I'm going to eat like a pastor,
I'm going to eat like a,
I'm an eat bread,
I'm going to eat,
uh,
you know,
whatever,
whatever.
I'm Anita Dessert after I'm have a cheesecake,
like I'm gonna eat all this stuff.
I don't eat,
I'm going to eat all this stuff.
I'd never eat.
Wow.
I'll make myself an Omelet,
you know,
I just,
I'll just,
we'll just crush it at night.
I crush it at night.
I crush it at night,
but I paid the price after,
you know,
after Ramadan,
I gotta lose the weight.
I got to get back in shape.
I got to,
you know,
it's,
I got,
it gives a lot of people would think that if you're not eating all day,
that you would lose weight.
Yeah.
Most people do Ramadan,
they lose weight.
Like everybody,
like I lost weight.
All his is mine.
And I'm like,
Hey guys,
I gained weight.
Why?
Because the thing is,
I know what I'm doing the next day.
It's going to be rough.
You know,
I'm not just working in an office.
I gotta,
I gotta move,
I gotta move my body.
So I packed the calories in the night before I hydrate and then I go into the
gym and I tried to make it like,
no.
I'm like,
I tried to do my routine as usual.
The hydrating part's got to be the most difficult.
That's got to be exhausting.
Yeah.
It's stuff.
Some fighters have actually gone through training camps while there are no,
it'd be like,
well,
how much?
Yeah,
very dangerous in my opinion,
and the risky while he won,
he won.
God bless him.
He's that crazy.
I have one of my fighters now.
He was doing Ramadan.
I was telling him off.
I was like,
listen,
you can't book a fight that do Ramadan.
It's one of the other,
you guys do your Ramadan after the fight,
but not during the camp.
This is too risky.
It's too dangerous.
He was literally sparked.
I was like,
dude,
why you look so flat that he's like,
I got to confess to you.
I'm like,
what is it?
I'm doing Ramadan?
I said,
dude,
you either to do Ramadan and cancel your fight or you book your fight.
I used to Ramadan after the two is dangerous.
It's not,
the Ramadan is not about putting yourself in danger.
Can you do Ramadan anytime you want?
If it,
if it interferes with your work,
you can do it after when it's convenient.
Okay,
so you don't have to do it uniformly w when everyone else is doing no,
because he has a fight booked.
It's his career.
That's how I put food on the table.
So you have an exception here.
Okay.
Do you Ramadan after your fight?
Like for instance,
[inaudible] mirrors that big tech.
He's doing his Ramadan after he just fought.
He's doing it afterwards.
Why?
Because during the cattle I was like,
look,
you're either doing Ramadan right and we're canceling the fight or you're going
to take your,
you know,
you need to do your job and you do ramen.
Then after,
and he was like,
okay,
I understand that's the way it's done.
You know,
he looked fantastic.
Did against the good jobs.
I mean,
it's just my mama's rather lamas is a,
a very tough veteran.
Ricardo has been around.
He's fought the best of the best.
He's,
she's fought for the title and that was a really,
really professional performance by Ricardo came to win.
And also,
I mean he had that creepy mustache to beck back ticks.
Creepy mustache.
Uh,
I think he's young.
He's exploring his looks,
you know,
experimenting with the creepy,
creepy mustache.
He's such a good kid though.
Hello.
It was a very nice guy,
but I was just super impressed with the way he handled llamas because llamas is,
he's,
I mean,
Lama says is well rounded as you're going to get these wrestlers get great
striking.
Great submission skills are like pretty much does any scene so much that for him
to win and wind down the stretch,
like he was overwhelming.
I'm deep into the sacrament and the third I was like,
well this is a guy that's clearly hitting his stride and [inaudible] next level.
Yeah,
he's,
he did a great job.
Now when a guy like that it's coming off of a fight like the Darren Elkins
fight,
how do you,
how do you build them back up after that fight?
Well,
you know what?
I feel like he was trying to do too much and he wore himself out in Elkins is
one of those guys where if you give them a window,
the fights over,
you know,
he's,
he's one of those,
those guys who's dangerous,
he knows what to do in the right and the particular situation,
he's not going to panic.
And he found the right right moment to beat,
uh,
Mirsada but I think just mears that overworked himself and he didn't find
pockets too.
Cause the thing is you cannot exert yourself at a maximum pace forever.
We've got to find pockets of recovery and get back to it.
I felt like he just a,
he overextended himself in the fight.
Yeah.
I feel like that was the case too.
But it's,
how do you know when to,
I mean,
how do you know when to push?
The idea is that you want to break your opponent,
right?
So how do you know when you're breaking yourself?
How do you know when your opponent has too much gas and you're not going to like
a guy like Elkins is famous for his durability in his heart,
so he's a,
he's an interesting case.
Yeah,
I think,
I think the master of that is George.
George recovers in the realm.
We always talk about recovering in the round and never showing the guy at your
maximum point.
Like let's say we're fighting me and you and I see you back off because you're
tired.
You're huffing and puffing and you sir,
I know you're breaking point now.
I know that if I push this pace a little bit more,
you're going to break.
There's no more reserves.
However,
if you get to about 70% of your fatigue and then you start circling and I see
you're circling,
but I don't see you're fatigued,
you're just doing that as a,
as a,
as a decoy.
You're playing mind games with me,
but really you're recovering.
You're playing mind games with me or circling your tying me up in ways you'd be,
you know that I'm never going to go over 70% I'm never going to red line in a
fight.
Only at the last bit of the fight am I going to red line because I have a
reserve in case things go wrong.
I have a reserve to explode out of a position that I might need,
so the only times I'll red line is if I'm in trouble in a fight and a half to go
all in because the fights can be over or it's the end of the fight.
The guys who go all in and around one for me,
eventually they will lose because some guy's going to weather that storm
sidestep and he's going to,
he's going to put the kill on you when you're,
when you're in recovery mode or like Francis and Ghana on Steep Immuno Church.
Right.
Francis came out guns blazing in the first round.
Blues Wad exactly in the second and the third.
Exactly.
Bate took over.
When you go for the kill,
you're risking losing the decision or losing afterwards.
If you don't get the kill,
if you over extent,
if you go all in,
yeah.
And there's no reserve,
you better get that kill because if you don't,
what's amazing is that when guys go all in in the first round,
even if they're in great shape,
sometimes they don't recover enough to complete the fight,
right.
If the guy they're fighting is skilled enough to not allow them that,
yeah.
You know,
if you roll with a blue belt,
you'll never get tired.
He doesn't have the skill to make me work.
Right.
However,
if I'm with a black belt and I get exhausted and now he's making me work,
right,
I may never recover.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
That's uh,
it's,
well,
it's not just,
it's also the way you go out.
If you go out full clip in that first round,
you,
you have essentially sprinted yourself into a position where you're just so
diminished.
There's so many fighters that are like that,
right?
Like Connor's kind of a good example.
Connor is fantastic in the beginning of a fight,
right.
But man,
he gets to them third,
fourth,
and fifth rounds and he takes it like the Nate Diaz fight the second fight.
He becomes human.
He turned and walked away from him.
I mean it was very human needed that break so badly.
When you see that,
do you think that that is a case of putting,
I don't want you to give away too much,
cause you know George potentially wants to fight coming in with the red.
Right.
Do you think that that's a case of poor conditioning?
Do you think that is a lack of experience in handling those moments because he's
so used to overwhelming people and taking them out early?
What do you think that is?
I think it's partly genetic.
Really?
Yes.
Because you see,
I call it the touch of death.
You know he's got that left hand.
It's the touch of death.
Yeah.
That touch of death comes at a cost.
Okay.
How do you have the touch of death?
Where does power come from?
Okay.
Well,
if you look up Michael Colgan or were talking about earlier,
he has a,
he has the criteria for power,
but to the best of his knowledge,
this is where he believes power comes from.
Okay.
So I can't teach Hussein bolt will be powerful.
I can only make him faster.
But where did that initial power come from?
Number one on the list.
Number one is where your muscle is attached to your bowl was genetic.
So Tyson hits,
he has a powerful left hook,
not because his coach taught him how to hit a left hook.
He could hit a left hook like that if you had a mediocre trainer.
It has to do with the leverage of his bolts.
So for instance,
uh,
you know,
if,
I'm going to imagine how like a,
like a really heavy poults weighs a hundred pounds and I want to stand it up,
well,
depending on where I grab it and then have more resistance or less resistance,
if I grab it near the end,
they have more leverage.
So where your muscles attached to your bone is gonna is gonna dictate how much
leverage you get out of it.
Second most important element is the type of muscle fiber you have,
the type.
So if you have a fast twitch muscle fiber,
you can hold this oxygen,
but he can switch faster,
hence the name.
So if you're a slow twitch muscle fiber guy,
you can metabolize more oxygen,
but she can't twitches fast.
So there's a give and take.
Nikki is exactly.
So you have a guy,
Nick Diaz,
who needs to knock you out with volume.
You can knock you out with one shot.
Let's look at Bj Penn.
If Ronald,
when he doesn't lock you out,
likelihood of knock you out.
Round two is less,
right?
Diaz is the opposite.
The likelihood of him knocking you out around
three is higher than Ron one.
Yeah,
because of the cumulative at the attack.
Yeah.
Mcgregor look at his stats.
It's all around one knockout run.
One knock out Ron,
Ron,
Ron to knock out.
He's fast twitch.
High leverage lefthand.
Yeah.
If you take them into deep waters,
his fast twitch muscle fibers cannot metabolize it.
Been with me whether maybe where they're so smart.
He let him work.
He let McGregor work for three rounds and you're getting excited.
Keep working,
keep working,
and when you have nothing left,
I'm going to put you out.
You know,
he,
there was such a brilliant strategy.
It was,
and it was so obvious how much more efficient he was.
Exactly.
No,
and more relaxed.
Connor had his moments early in the fight where he,
he hit him with someone,
an unorthodox punches and some,
some weird movement.
But after a while it was just,
I found both of them had a brilliant performance cause when Mcgregor did to go
in his world,
oh crap.
It's brilliant.
It was brilliant.
Just crazy crazy that that had even happened.
Really.
Stop and think about it.
It's almost like the world got a magic trick.
It was unbelievable.
I want George to fight Mayweather.
I keep bothering you.
Fight me with it.
You fight it.
He's like,
it's crazy.
I know it's crazy,
but I bet may whether it would do it.
That's what I'm saying.
George might have to lose a shitload of weight.
Yeah,
they'll find a catch weight.
Do you think Mayweather?
His word,
he's going to get concussed.
He's fought all the top punches in the world.
Right.
He's just gonna have to worry about George's volume in reach,
but he can handle himself and George can have the limb itself,
but the whole world is going to tune into that one.
You know what I'm saying?
I like George is selling it like,
yeah,
do it,
man.
Do it.
But George doesn't want to fight.
A smaller guy doesn't want to call out a smarter guy,
so it's going to have to come from me.
Whether it's going to have to file.
There's another big money fight.
Yep.
But is it a bit as big a money fight?
That's the thing.
The real big money fight is in somehow or another McGregor convincing the world
that he could beat him in the second fight.
Like I know there were weather.
Yes.
That's a hard sell.
It's a hard sell.
We bought that one already.
Yeah,
we bought that one,
George,
to fight Mcgregor.
There was the one thing of doing it in the octagon and doing it with small
gloves and no kicks.
I remember there was,
there was some talk of that and people were like,
well,
where's this talk coming from?
I don't know if it was legit or not.
I called Dana.
Dana said,
it's 100% bullshit,
but I'm getting the state can enforce that.
If Mcgregor wants to throw a kick,
he'll throw a kick.
Right.
It has to be gentleman's rule.
Do you remember when that happened with Tim Silvia and Ray Mercer?
No.
Tim Silvia fought Ray Mercer and they had originally been scheduled to fight a
boxing match Edelman's rules,
but the commission said they wouldn't sanction the fight because Tim Silvia
doesn't have any pro boxing experience.
Ray Mercer Olympic gold medal as former world champion and they decided to have
an MMA fight,
but they had a gentleman's agreement to not throw kicks.
Tim Opens up with an inside leg kick.
You ever seen a fight?
They,
I did this.
I just forgot about the chick.
It starts off and Tim Silvia immediately.
Oh,
this is go before this,
go.
Before this cause this is,
that's the Kao.
If you go before this,
they open up and Tim kicks him right away and let ray see raid puts his hands
down.
Your mother fucker.
I can't believe this shit.
Oh,
that's why he didn't give a look.
And then he hit some ways down.
He's just share.
Oh Zim,
let me see that one more time.
Oh boom.
I mean come on son.
And that's like a 50 year old ray Mercer at the tile.
Wow.
Ray.
He,
that's why he gave him that look.
He was like,
he couldn't believe it.
He's like,
I thought we weren't kicking man.
So they have made a gentleman's agreement and Tim Silvia was like,
yeah,
whatever dude.
But he paid for that.
I mean he got starched.
That was,
that's,
it's also the difference in skill level.
You see a guy like ray Mercer who's seen all these patterns and a guy like Tim
Silvia has just so used to MMA fighters striking.
It's a different,
different speed.
Also.
It is.
How much does it help fighters to cross train in these different disciplines and
how difficult is it to take those skills and then to put them into their overall
MMA game?
I think it's beneficial if you do it to a certain degree because if you go too
much less,
he always spargel pro boxers.
There's a distance.
It's not realistic because in MMA you're further away from each other.
Yeah,
so when I get to that distance,
the guy's going to grab me.
However,
because there's more punches per second.
It's more of an intensive training.
So if you can deal with that speed of training,
then later when I put you in MMA zone,
when it's slower a little bit.
So there's that element.
There's a balancing act as there's a boxing with a pro boxer,
but then there's doing it too much that when you're sparring with MMA fighter,
it's harder to hit.
That may may fighter than it is for me to hit the boxer.
Right,
because we're in a different pattern were different worlds.
I want to do just a bit of that.
Not Too much.
Is there,
are there any patterns that people pick up in boxing that become a real problem
when you add in elbows?
Yeah.
When you ducked down,
some guys just start,
okay,
you throw up your hand.
I'm going to duck down.
Dude,
you do that once with me.
I'm throwing a left kick right after Moran.
I'm throwing a shallow right hand and the left kicks coming upstairs and when
you slip you're slipping right into the kick.
Jon Jones.
Daniel Cormier.
Exactly.
I mean that was a pattern that John had seen and they even talked about it
beforehand with Dennis said,
don't think you're going to hit me with that left high kick,
which is kind of crazy when you see how it went down.
Yeah.
That's a weird thing when people just develop a sort of pattern that they just
keep repeating over and over again and then it's instinctual.
You want to take it out now?
Ooh,
good luck.
Good luck.
Taken it out.
This and that.
That's one of the things that when you see people learning technique,
one of the more difficult things is to relearn something once you learn it.
One way,
like with the kicking in particular when they get tired or when they get
nervous,
they revert back to their old way of kicking and you you see it.
Especially if they learned it young.
Yeah,
it's hardwired.
Yeah.
How do you get a guy out of that?
I haven't been very successful.
Like for instance,
if I take a guy who has been kicking taekwondo his entire life and then I tried
to teach him a Thai kick,
it's not that easy.
It's really difficult.
Yeah.
That's why I believe when you're young you have to have a diversity.
You have learn how to kick like a tie,
like a taekwondo guy,
like a karate guy,
like a kickboxer,
the variety,
and then you can go out there and you can morph your style.
You can exchange from one style of kicking to another.
However,
if you've done 10 years of one way and you are hardwired that way,
it's very difficult.
Almost not worth it to we do it.
Just let him kick the way he kicks real.
Yeah.
It's not worth it.
Not Worth it.
No,
because you're going to treat him for him for so many hours.
Then he's going to go in there.
He's going to revert back.
Like you said,
when he's under the pressure and the stress is going to revert back to what he
normally does when he's a little bit tired because it's more efficient for him.
Mm.
So you're asking him now to do something new.
Is there any way to rewire a person's brain?
Not that I know of.
Not,
not in that.
Not.
Of course you can.
You can change someone's behavior.
Absolutely.
But if it's hardwired from a young age,
we're talking about it's a long term project.
Do you have the amount of time you could do it?
But it's a lot of time and energy and it's painful.
It's painful to undo an old way.
Yeah.
It's a lot of energy.
The guy will feel tired of the Gulf feel sluggish,
like I'll feel uncomfortable because he's doing something inefficient.
You see those patterns though where where you watch a guy fight and you go,
man,
why does he always do that?
He's always throwing these wide looping punches like why can he throw a fish,
smooth technical punches.
He might've learned,
I've,
I've had that problem.
They learned that wrong early on in the career.
Then when they get to you,
they're good enough to get to you.
They're good enough to,
you know,
come near the UFC another other.
They want that next level and you're working with this new athlete who has so
many inefficiencies.
You've got to remove them one by one gently.
If you try to re haul him,
you just confused him and he just doesn't know what to do anymore.
What do you want me to do coach?
Like I'm totally lost.
It's,
it's like a,
it's like a scientific experiment,
right?
You isolate one variable.
If you change too many things,
we don't know what caused what anymore and you're in it.
You're in a chaotic,
now you're now you're in a world of chaos.
He doesn't know what works anymore.
You don't know what's wrong.
Anyway,
w one thing at a time.
We don't want to flood you and we don't want to bottleneck queue what we're
taking.
You go from one place to another,
one step at a time gently and you have to ask yourself,
what's the one thing I can help this guy with?
The one thing they had,
they'll change the rest of the system.
This is the most important thing.
And let's do that one thing at a time.
So when you see a guy and say,
look,
he's got a kill Christian background or something like that and you see he
throws kicks but he keeps landing with the instep.
You just let him keep doing it like that.
Um,
yeah.
It depends how many years he has and how much time we have before the next fight
because I believe it can work.
It works.
The reason why karate is still here is because it worked,
right guys.
One right.
You know,
it's exists.
Friday's not,
and it's not a bad spasm.
It works.
If you can make it work,
I might teach a quality guys in boxing and then his karate will shine even more
cause he could bust.
Yeah,
that does seem to be the problem is when,
I mean,
um,
taekwondo guides in particular,
they don't punch to the face.
So when they get into sparring situations and they're first learning how to do
it,
and we saw that with Raymond Daniels early in his career as well,
just have the hardest time with hands.
Mm.
So do you take a guy like that and just have them only box or,
I would make them bucks a lot and that'll open up his kicks even more.
Definitely no doubt about it.
Especially with his reach and his,
his,
uh,
his distance,
his foot work that he has.
You can look,
uh,
he could do a lot more,
I think.
Do you write all this stuff down?
Like your thoughts on these things?
I know you do your youtube series and you have,
but have you ever considered putting out a book on your ideas?
I'm writing a book,
but it's more fun.
It's more of a philosophy book.
Then next I have a background philosophy.
Have a degree in philosophy.
So I spend a lot of time just contemplating things.
So I do a lot of fight philosophy stuff.
I write it down,
publish a book,
not really interested in that to be honest with you.
I'm more interested in going in philosophy,
writing about philosophy,
not so much MMA,
like philosophy,
uh,
more about chew with reality,
a paradigms,
you know,
how,
how we see the world,
you know,
what is truth,
what is reality,
those kinds of things.
I know it sounds weird that's coming from an MMA coach,
but I do a lot of philosophy on my own,
in my own personal life.
I don't think it's weird at all.
I mean I think that what you do is essentially your taking fighters in preparing
them for one of the most difficult challenges in all professional sports.
And I don't think there's,
I don't think there's a more difficult challenge.
It's outside of war.
Yeah,
exactly.
No.
Or being a firefighter or a police officer where you actually putting your life
in danger.
I think.
Yeah,
combat sports or just,
it's extremely difficult to do and to be able to do like what you've done with
George and what George has done as well.
I mean what you guys have done together,
it's just an incredible accomplishment and especially him coming back after four
years off and looking better than he ever looked in the past.
That was what was crazy when he came back and the fluidity of his combinations,
the way he looked and the way he sunk that rear naked choke,
that was a rare rear naked choke and MMA where the blade of the hand was on the
back of the neck and it was just fully sunk in.
You know that that you don't really see guys get the choke,
but you're seeing that old school Ken shamrock style back on their attempt to
this.
I'll never talk to this.
You put me on if the hand's is not behind [inaudible] you'd rather get put put
out.
It's funny,
I was reading one of my students yesterday and I let him take him out.
Like I was kind of toying with him and let him take my back and he was stronger
than I thought.
He was like he,
I haven't wrestled with him in 10 years.
I just put out a youtube video of me and him.
If you guys want to put it up,
it would be funny,
but this is,
we were rolling off camera and I kind of let him take my back and I never give
up my bag,
but sometimes I know he's probably about,
so I'll just kind of toying with him a little and he put a choke kid and I was
like,
okay,
let's see if he can finish.
I didn't think he could finish it.
Then all of a sudden you've got in deeper and he didn't have the hand behind my
head,
so I was like,
I'm not going to tap.
No Way.
I would have to this impossible.
First of all,
he should know better.
Okay.
If I let them tap me with this,
he's gonna think he did it right.
So I was like,
no.
But I was like,
eh.
And then when he took a breath,
I just took,
I just took his hand out because I could reach your hand.
Right.
It's not tucked away behind it.
And I got out.
I'll never talked to this man.
Never.
So he's doing this.
Yeah.
His hand,
he's like,
here it has to be here.
That MMA gloves or uh,
no,
flow.
Fluor full.
Really?
Yeah.
He's a good purple belt.
He's tough guy.
Very good shape.
Strong.
And the is not in the zoo.
That was off camera,
but I mean,
I would never talk to this like even in practice because it's not on the choke
is not on,
right,
right.
Yeah.
There's definitely a difference,
but some guys have gotten it even in the UFC with just a gable grip.
The guys,
the guy who,
the guy who was being choked.
Oh,
with the Gable grip works,
because I kind of grew,
I kind of grab your hand.
Hmm.
I see what you're saying.
Like if your hand is here and I can grab it,
why would I choke?
Why would I,
why would I tap?
I can hold your hand.
I can grab onto it.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
It's funny that in the early days that was how everyone did a real nice,
it was more chronic.
It's more panic.
You okay,
oxygen is lower and you're topping,
but you're not going to go out.
People just didn't know any better.
Exactly.
That was okay to do.
Right.
It's not that that palm and the back of the head was okay to do.
I don't know who figured out to do this.
No problem behind the head is is okay.
I'm not against that.
It's when the hand is top of the head bride,
it has to be unreachable.
If I can reach it,
I'm not tapping.
Right.
I'm not tired it.
I forget that.
Why would it happen?
It's,
it's an experience a few times.
It's like you,
you panicked a bit.
What's your feeling though on tapping?
Because here's the thing about tapping like this.
I've had some injuries were like,
fuck,
I should have just tap and I got out of it and I kept rolling and then my elbows
fucked.
I can't do chin ups for a couple of months.
Top quick.
I don't have to,
strangle holds easily except for gala things.
I feel like a torque my neck,
but a rear naked,
there's no joint issue so I won't top,
I'm stubborn as the next guy.
My joints I top right away and I don't,
I don't put any miles on my joints and I want to be as good as it can be,
as healthy as it can be.
It cause I want to roll till I'm,
you know,
like the week before I die.
I want to be rolling the week before.
Well that's the ultimate goal that very few people ever achieve.
Every I know so many Jujitsu guys that are so busted up.
Like Eddie Bravo has an artificial disc in his lower back.
Both of his shoulders are completely fucked and he's trying to avoid surgery in
his shoulders.
And he's knee too,
right?
Cause I was just with him in Vegas,
his ACL,
he had a tear in his ACL and then he just got his knee operated on.
He had a bucket handle tear,
so he got his meniscus repaired.
But his,
uh,
his ACL was,
at least partially torn and he,
he's letting it heal.
But I'm very skeptical about people that just let Parsha tail tears in
[inaudible] here.
Cause I feel like,
yeah,
you let it heal,
but it healed with like 60% of its original strength.
Like you might have led and heal,
but how much did you know there's a weakness?
Yeah.
You know what they're doing now,
which is really fascinating.
Dr Roddy Mcgee out of Las Vegas,
who does a lot of work with UFC fighters,
he's showing me that they're taking torn ACL is completely torn and instead of
replacing it now with a cadaver graft or Patella tendon graft,
they actually take that ligament and can reattach it.
Really.
And in three months they had someone competing in the Olympics.
Really?
Yes.
What's his name?
Doctor Rati Magee.
Wow.
Yeah.
Cutting edge.
Ms here in the u s Yup.
Widest and greatest.
And they're doing it.
It's a crazy operation.
They're taking this broken ligament and they obviously have to do it quick
before it pulls back and disintegrates.
But when it gets to the,
they get the torrent,
the tear in it,
they reattach it and they,
so the shit out of this thing,
they've got like stitches in it and it's all weirdly bound up.
And then it reattaches if reattaches and actually grows your original ligament
as well.
It's not,
you know,
that your body can reject or something that you're,
you don't have to compromise your patella tendon,
you know,
I don't know how George had his done.
Did he do the Patella tendon graft?
I feel like you did with one of them.
[inaudible] they don't have a string of,
can't remember.
He didn't,
he didn't take ever,
he took his own to do it both ways.
Both Times the same way?
I think so.
Yeah.
If I remember correct,
Matt,
uh,
Matt Brown just did a hamstring.
He just had his done and they did a hamstring and he said it's,
he feels pretty good already.
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's scary injury.
Oh,
I've had bolt on.
Really?
Yeah.
I've had a one with a patella tendon graft and one with a cadaver.
The cadaver was much easier for me.
Really?
Yeah.
It took,
yeah.
I don't see the thing about it taking,
you're not taking the idea.
What happens with the cadaver is people think that you're,
your body takes it like an artificial heart.
No.
Or like a,
you know,
a transplanted heart.
It actually uses it as a scaffolding to re proliferate with your own cells.
And I think part of the problem is it gives you the feeling that it's stronger
than it is early on you're like,
yeah,
I'm ready to go.
And you start,
you mean everybody wants to start rolling again?
Everybody wants to start training again.
And so I think some guys just get in there a little bit too early and they do
something and it pops and they go,
oh,
it didn't take well.
Is that really the case or did you just put too much stress on it too early on?
I thought the fear was it can reject your body,
can reject it.
I've heard of that,
but I think that's extremely rare.
Okay.
I think what,
what's more common is that they say it doesn't take like that it didn't,
but I think what I hear it from MMA guys,
it's like,
I know you are a meathead.
I know you guys are savages.
You get in there and you're training hard way earlier than you should be and
then it fucks up again.
I mean,
there's a bunch of guys that have got an ACL surgery and then in the recovery
process blew it out again.
It happens really common and then they're back to square one again.
Right?
It's all narratives.
I mean,
even the,
I mean to,
to explain something,
it's,
it's really just,
it's narrative.
That's what our explanations are 99% of the time.
Just narratives and then to weed out narratives and not use them.
It's very difficult.
What household,
what do you mean by that?
Um,
I mean there are differences between
logical arguments,
empirical observations,
and then there are narratives.
We tell ourselves why things are happening around this all the time.
And it's 99% of the time it's wrong.
But we believe it.
We tell ourselves that.
And to try to work around that is,
is actually quite difficult.
So like for instance,
uh,
when,
when the field of philosophy and if you give an argument,
if you give a deductive argument,
your argument has to conclude the conclusion has to have no other possibility.
It can be no other possibility.
All your premises have to be valid and sound and there can be no other
possibility.
When I say,
Hey,
my ligament didn't take,
there's a thought.
That's an explanation.
It's one of many possible narratives.
It's one of,
it's one of many,
many possible explanations I couldn't give.
Why might,
why my knee's injured now including that you didn't give it,
let it rest enough.
Right?
Let's say I'm walking and I trip over my shoelaces and maybe like I tripped over
my shoelaces.
That's why I felt,
well,
you could made if your shoelaces were untied,
maybe trip anyway.
Maybe it was something else,
right?
You haven't,
you haven't eliminated every other possibility if you haven't eliminated every
other possibility.
It's just a narrative.
It's not actual fact.
The Tony Ferguson injury was the most fucked up one I've ever,
ever right the week of the fight,
press trips on some cables and rips his knee apart.
For sure.
He had an injury before.
He is not aware of you think so.
There had to be a small rip,
a small tear,
a small weakness somewhere.
Ain't no way he can win.
He could withstand shipping on a,
on a,
on a cable,
but I mean it was hanging by a thread.
Is that the case or did it,
did he just followed a really fucked up man?
I didn't see the fall,
but I assume he's a athletic guy and you could fall in a way he can catch
himself falling in a way that,
you know,
is his athletic.
He may be,
he had,
you know,
when you're sparring,
you hurt yourself.
You don't feel it so much is going on.
Maybe he hurt himself when he cooled down and he didn't feel it.
It's not,
there's not many pain sensors there or whatnot.
Again,
this is just a narrative,
right?
Then he goes in there,
it's hanging by a thread.
He tugs it,
boom.
The whole thing breaks apart,
you know,
it's,
well,
it's a possibility.
It's such a violent injury.
If you see how bad it was.
Did you see the surgery photos?
I saw,
I saw actually a little bit the craziest photos I've ever seen.
I mean his,
it's a fucking enormous scar to have that kind of a scar in 2018 while the
surgery techniques they have today.
It's very rare that you see someone who's just,
I mean it's,
you're looking at like a 12 inch scar really?
That I didn't see,
I just saw him.
He posted an Oh my God.
Wow.
That's huge.
It's credible.
I mean that,
that is a giant scar goes well below his knee to above the knee and they opened
him up.
And what does this,
is this pre surgery?
What does that,
so this is just different angles at ACL.
What was it?
No,
his MCL.
A PCL out.
Which one is on the outside?
Outside is MCL.
So as MCL was ripped,
completely bone.
Wow.
Yeah,
man.
What Gilda?
His Twitter is Instagram page.
Now does he have,
um,
and the updates because a guy like that,
you gotta wonder like,
when is he going photo I saw the one with the Suction Cup is copping.
Is that okay?
Let me ask you this.
Cause I was just having a conversation with someone who was it that just say a
cup and was bullshit.
It was a,
was it,
I was having a conversation with someone.
They're saying cupping is essentially almost total nonsense,
but so many people do it and it just puts your mind that you're doing something
and healing and doing something,
you know,
addition in addition to standard procedures to that that's helping you out but
really ain't doing shit.
Um,
I would say,
yeah,
it's probably more psychological,
but everybody does it.
Yeah,
it's fun.
It's like a logical,
you feel like you're taking care of yourself and it makes you feel good.
It's psychosomatic.
It's funny because back up,
hold on,
go back up to that image of Jamie.
I mean,
look,
look at that.
That is fucking crazy looking.
It is.
Yeah.
But you know,
psychosomatic medicine can help you.
But hearsay,
an insurance covers acupuncture treatment because it's effective.
I was skeptical the first time I tried it,
but it,
yeah.
See,
I don't know.
You are a complete moron then.
Even insurance covers acupuncture.
Well,
does acupuncture work?
I have no idea.
Never tested.
Never fucked with it.
I've had it done to me.
I didn't particularly enjoyed it.
Yeah.
I only had it done once and the guy was kind of acquired.
And I was like,
all right.
He didn't,
once they start talking about toxins,
you know,
we're cleansing you toxins.
Like,
oh,
that's a narrative.
Yeah.
Possible.
Let's not prove it.
Right.
It's a possible story you told yourself.
Yeah.
But that term toxins is so that that is like,
there's certain things that people say,
well,
you know,
you're dealing with a woo,
oh,
this is some bullshit here.
And toxins is one of them.
Cleansing and toxins.
I'm going into a class and I'm,
I'm getting the toxins out of my system.
The scientists are just as guilty as of Wu is every other guy.
You think so?
Oh yeah.
In what way?
Oh my God,
man.
Like there's,
there's scientists,
then there's philosophers of science.
There's so much Wu in science,
even the most popular guys have woo.
They just never studied the philosophy of science.
So they don't really understand what they're saying per say.
Like,
give me an example of wounds.
I'll give you,
I'll give you a great,
he's okay.
Okay.
Um,
there's this guy named Isaac Newton.
Okay,
I heard of that dude.
Yeah.
And you're asking him,
Hey Isaac,
why don't I fall off the face of the earth?
And he's going to be like,
well,
Joe,
there's this gravity.
This is the force of gravity pulling you down to the earth.
The earth has a greater mass than you.
Therefore it's,
there's this force pulling you down.
We call it gravity.
And then some guy comes around,
his name is,
is a hobby.
And he tells,
you know,
Joel,
don't listen to that guy.
I have another theory.
Way more that's
shorter than his.
I believe there are gremlins pulling it down to the earth.
They have last holes.
He's infinite.
Long last was,
and every time you're falling off the,
if they pull you,
every time you jump up and down on the earth,
they pull you back down to the earth.
You don't see these gremlins are invisible,
but that's what's pulling you down to the earth.
Now,
how do you know who's right and who's wrong?
Who's telling you the truth?
Mere Isaac.
Well,
Isaac lived a long time ago before they actually had provable studies that could
show you why gravity works.
Naming one of those studies.
Well,
I'm not a scientist.
No side.
Let me,
let me break it to you this way.
No scientist has a study to prove us that gravity works.
That's,
that's the whole thing.
that's what's scary about.
But can you talk about the universal and understand that gravity is in relation
to the size and mass of objects.
So the moon is smaller,
therefore it has one six earth's gravity cause it's one quarter the size of the
earth.
There's a standard formula that you follow.
There's a correlation.
Now My,
my theory of Gremlins,
which obviously I don't believe in,
right?
I'm using the theological language to make it really sip though.
Somebody misquote me that I've even really know
he doesn't believe in gravity is gravity denier.
Exactly.
Well,
I have,
there's less.
There's less mass.
There's less Adams.
The moon has less Adams.
Therefore less Gremlin.
Lesser than pulling.
You might.
My gremlin theory correlates with the gravity theory.
Exactly,
but I'm using a myth,
mythical language.
Just to point out that every type of force we're talking about is an inference.
It's something we project out there.
We don't actually see gravity and you know later on,
Einstein debunked gravity,
right?
When?
What do you mean by he dunk gravity?
Isaac was totally wrong.
I think explanation of why you don't fall off the earth was totally wrong.
Well,
what did Einstein due to debunk it?
Einstein taught us that a new theory and new hypothesis that gravity's a pushing
force,
not a pulling force.
See Isaac Newton,
he debunked Aristotle
first.
We to believe what Aristotle used to say.
I was starting to say,
look,
this thing has a natural place.
It has to be stuck to the earth.
That's just natural place it the forces within that one thing.
That's why it doesn't fall off theorists.
So when Aristotle saw bird fly,
he said it,
look,
it has levity.
It's natural state is to be in the air.
The force that carries it up in the air,
it's within it.
Within the bird itself.
Isaac Newton came around and said,
no,
that's totally wrong.
Nobody,
no,
no entity can move itself.
It's only a force that's applied.
So let's say you're walking Isaac Newton would say you're not pushing yourself
forward.
You're pushing the ground beneath you backwards
and that the ground is pushing you forwards so that every action has an
opposite,
equal reaction.
So when I run,
I'm really pushing the ground behind me.
It sounds like,
like he's splitting hairs,
but he's saying something actually very profound.
He saying,
you're pushing the earth behind you and the earth is pushing you forward.
There's a reaction there.
So what they do to,
to illustrate that to kids is they take like a train track,
the elevated and the turn on the train,
and then you see the train tracks don't spin underneath the train.
And it's showing you look,
the train is pushing the train tracks back and the train tracks are pushing the
train forward when they're,
when they're connected to the ground.
So the,
when I put you on a treadmill,
you're pushing the treadmill behind you,
the treadmill's not pushing you forward because it's,
it's spinning along with you.
And if I put you on the ground,
the ground is pushing you forward now,
so for every action has an opposite,
equal reaction.
I'm sure you heard this.
Then Einstein comes along and says,
no,
that's totally wrong when it comes to gravity.
Okay?
When subject to gravity says,
because Isaac Newton says this,
look,
he says,
the force of gravity is in the earth.
The earth has this invisible force,
this magical wool thing.
And that's what,
that's what is contemporary set about him.
That's what his pure said.
He said,
all you're appealing to magic.
What is gravity thing where it's not,
it's not comparable.
It's not material.
It's not made of a substance is this magic.
And he was like,
yeah,
it's this forced.
You can't feel it.
You can detect it.
It's just observable in the nature and for 300 years everybody believed that and
then I think as long says no,
you guys are totally wrong.
There is no mythical force called gravity.
It's a pushing force.
So really what he says is,
sorry,
let me,
let me get a sheet of paper here.
Make a really,
really simple,
and I'm going to put it in a nutshell here.
Okay.
But okay,
this is,
he says,
look,
I just says look,
space and time are one space is actually a thing out there.
It's actually a fee.
The space between me and you is the actual physical thing.
He says the sun is so heavy that it dents it,
that makes it,
it makes like a totally the bowl and the earth is bumping around in that toilet
bowl because space is actually curved.
It's curved like this spaces curve because the sun,
Imagine I put something,
a bowling ball on your bed.
You,
your,
your bed's going to indent that bolt,
that toilet bowl shape the world.
The earth is flooring around that toilet bowl shape.
So it's a pushing force.
No longer a pulling force.
So the weight of the earth is pushing down on space.
Exactly.
It's bending space.
Literally it's masses bending space.
Now Isaac Newton thought light travels in a straight line only.
And to prove this,
Einstein said,
look,
light will bend if I'm right.
Light Bend.
So they observe the sun during an eclipse and they saw that the light bends
light does not travel in a straight line.
This was another,
um,
uh,
belief there was debunked.
I mean,
how many scientific beliefs are debunked countless or overturned because a
scientific fact is not a mathematical fact.
They're two different things as scientific fact and never go higher than
hypothesis.
If somebody understands the philosophy of science,
he understands that every single scientific fact is not equivalent to a
mathematical fact.
One plus one equals to a scientific fact is always subject to cross examination
and new evidence.
Well,
you've ever heard of Thomas Kuhn is very famous for that,
right?
We have a paradigm.
So during Aristotle's time he had a paradigm.
You thought the sun goes around the earth.
It was an observational,
scientific fact.
Everyday he saw the sun go around the earth.
Literally.
He said,
look guys,
I'm
using my senses to observe the sun go around the earth.
And then one day we find that no,
that's an optical illusion.
It's not sure that the sun goes around the earth is the earth goes around the
sun site.
They re scientific revolution.
Every scientific fact we have,
or theory including gravity,
because gravity became the law of gravity.
It wasn't a longer the theory of gravity,
it was so accepted became the law of gravity.
Today we don't,
we don't understand gravity as Einstein understood it.
Excuse me,
as Isaac Newton understood it.
We understand it completely backwards,
literally backwards now.
And that's true with every scientific theory because science is always subject
to new evidence coming to light or the difference between Isaac Newton living
with when,
whenever the fuck he lived a long ass time ago,
300 years ago versus the science that we're dealing with today.
Like it's a sense today,
but what we'll,
we'll do you see in the science of today?
Um Oh the biggest culprit.
Yes.
A randomness.
See,
it's funny cause I heard you just conversation with the Sam Harris on
randomness,
which I loved by the way.
You did a great job.
I thought it was a great conversation.
However he was giving you my opinion.
Two contradictory ideas was tell you,
look the world is determined but also there'll be random events.
And I found that all he was actually talking about determinism versus free will,
right?
Yeah.
So the idea being that you don't necessarily have free will that everything
about your decisions and what you're going to do is based on your life
experiences,
your genetics,
all these variables that are essentially out of your control.
So this idea of free will is an illusion,
which is a really complex conversation.
And I think you could see it in both ways.
I think you do have a certain amount of control of your decisions.
And I think you were also shaped very much so by your past and your genetics and
your interpretation of those events.
Um,
what are those interpretations of those events though?
And why do you make those determinations?
W who,
who's,
who's in your head pulling the gears?
Like what?
What are you,
I'm a hard determinist like I'm a very hard determinist.
Like I'm,
I'm like determinist extremist,
so but do you believe in free will?
I also believe in free will,
which is,
which is to,
which is tricky.
Yeah.
It's tricky,
but I think that's what it's true.
A potting the both further examination.
I think that there's,
there is something that allows people to,
I mean what,
what takes the guy was 500 pounds and all of sudden he goes on a Keto diet and
starts running and who starts walking in the knee,
he sends you a picture on Twitter.
I lost 179 pounds in six months.
You're like,
Holy Shit,
how the fuck did you do?
Like that guy has some fucking wheel man to say that.
That's his whole life and his life experiences and as genetics it's like,
yes,
I could see what you're saying.
I could see that he,
he had enough because of his life experiences and that it led to him making this
change,
but this is a tremendous amount of will involved in that and to deny that seems
like you're denying the spirit of human beings.
Well,
let's look at it this way.
Okay,
real quick,
let's look at it like,
okay,
let's say a couple of this piece of paper
and I'm going to catapult it.
Okay,
in Atlanta there,
right,
and I'm going to reset the entire universe.
I'm going to reset every molecule there.
Every fiber in this paper,
you're going to be in the exact same spot.
The whole universe has been reset and a fire.
It again,
isn't going to land exactly where it landed the first time,
or is it going to land somewhere else?
I've reset the universe.
The earth was the earth.
Every molecule of matter in the every,
every,
every particle of matter in the universe has been reset with the same amount of
force.
Everything is identical.
I would assume if the same amount of space and the same amount of air,
you would land the same spot infinitely.
Precisely.
I don't know what every set,
everything perfectly,
infinitely,
precisely.
You throw it a dax exact same way and it lands in the exact same dirt with the
exact same resistance.
It's the same thing.
I would assume it's infinitely precisely going to land the same spot if random.
This is a force at work in nature.
Why did [inaudible] factor itself into our little experiment here?
Cause you little experiments.
Impossible.
But that's irrelevance.
A thought experiment.
But it's,
it's not creating a logical universe.
Right,
but it's not logically impossible.
Right?
Well,
in that case though,
with the variables that you presented.
Yes.
Okay,
well where's randomness?
Where's this?
Four is no randomness.
If you're recreating the entire earth in a in a very duplicatable way,
that's not randomness at all.
It is random.
There's nothing.
There is no randomness,
right?
Random.
This is when a human being can no longer compute all the factors and he,
we use an expression called randomness,
meaning,
okay,
I rolled the dice had landed on on seven randomly.
Why?
Because I couldn't compute all the variables.
Okay.
Series.
So the random,
this is kind of a,
it's a,
it's an illusion that we project onto the world.
So La Plas,
one of the greatest physicists in history,
okay.
A similar place.
He says,
look,
look at a billiard ball table.
Okay?
If you tell me which way you're going to break the billiard balls,
if you tell me what philocity and what angle you're gonna hit the cue ball,
I could tell you where every single ball is going to be on the pool table.
That's what laplace says.
Okay?
He's a phenomenal thinker.
And he says,
why?
Because I'm going to take that table.
I'm going to turn it to a math.
I'm going to take the weight of the ball.
The friction of the table,
the,
the density of the bands,
the gravity of the earth.
Excuse me.
I'm going to take all those variables.
I'm going to put them up on this board here.
All they need to know is how hard you can hit the ball and I'll tell you
precisely where every ball is going to lend.
Now,
somebody who doesn't know mathematics or geometry is going to look at that table
when he sees the break to him.
It's going to seem random but random.
This is really a reflection of his ignorance.
He's not able to compute all this information.
That's why the plas says to God the world is not random to somebody who has
information.
The world is not random.
That's why he says it was very important.
That's weight.
That's why we're sold deterministic because we believe that what's happening
right now is a byproduct of the past.
The past caused this happening right now.
The past was out of your control.
If I the universe
and let it play all over again,
I identical circumstances,
you would drink that exact same amount of coffee you had today.
You would have made the same,
have married the same woman,
you would have had the same kids.
You would have had the same t shirt on.
Right now you would have the Mike at the same.
This everything would be reset.
So when we look at the world through the eyes of physics,
they say the cause of Linus complete the cause of Linus.
Complete meaning where is this space for randomness or freewill?
It w we don't factor it in.
The only time we do factor it in is when we look at ourselves inwardly.
But when we look at the world objectively as a third person,
so there's two views.
There's an internal view of first person experience.
We don't believe,
we don't believe in determinism.
We were,
we have free will.
That's first person experience.
Third Person Experience.
I'm studying Joe.
All I see in Joe is billiard balls.
So when you have a thought,
it's all billiard balls hitting one another.
And if I had an infinitely precise calculator,
it according to the a plus,
I could tell you where you're going to be five years from now,
what you're going to be doing.
Why?
Because I'm seeing one billiard ball hit another.
It's just take that pool table,
experiment and make it the greatest pool game in history.
There are countless atoms.
There are countless billiard balls striking into one another.
Somebody can calculate the world of physics and tell you where your hand's going
to be.
Laplas says,
I'm going to tell you where your hand's going to be in five years from now,
but you don't know my personal choices.
I'm going to make it.
That's irrelevant.
That's a way he'll tell you.
Why?
Because he sees the billiard balls moving inside your mind,
so to speak.
Now Leipnetz reconcile the two because see,
for instance,
when I,
when I living in the first person,
this is my intuition,
I'm like,
Hey,
I grabbed that Coffee Cup of coffee.
I had this internal experience.
It's outside of physics.
So Lyman has gives a great example.
He says,
look,
if I was really,
really tiny and I'd walk around in your mind,
I would see blood flow.
I would see neurons firing.
I would see all sorts of biological interactions,
but I wouldn't see anything of consciousness.
I wouldn't see your thoughts.
I wouldn't see you thinking about your wife,
a hearing,
your child's voice,
thinking about what you want to have for dinner.
I wouldn't see any of that.
I would just see billiard balls hitting one another.
However,
now that I'm having this first person experience,
there's something we call intuition.
This first person experience itself,
you're having this spiritual type of transcendent experience.
What it's like to have a thought,
what it's like to be me.
So for instance,
I see the cup of coffee,
I desire the cup of coffee and I drink it.
Science has nothing that has no information about my conscious experience,
my intuitive experience it.
The science is not absolute.
It cannot tell me everything about the universe.
It could only tell me about the billiard balls.
It can only go so far.
At that point,
it has to stop because it doesn't have,
we don't,
our senses cannot sense.
The conscious experience that we're having.
The conscious experience is only known intuitively.
So first person experience,
so 11 it says this.
It says,
look,
you look at the world when you study the world,
we're all seeing billiard balls hitting one another.
Nobody argues about that.
However,
our intuition is telling as that's all untrue.
We have the chat.
We have the ability to move our own hand,
desire something,
grab something,
eat something,
consumed something,
make a choice.
And he says,
how are the two,
how can they coexist?
Because remember in reason for me to accept something as logically true after
eliminate every other possibility.
So he found the one possibility,
one possibility that till today it's never been refuted.
He says that he calls it the the twin trains.
So picture two trains.
Okay?
They're going up and down,
side by side,
traveling at the same speed.
They look like they're connected to one another,
but they're not.
They're just synchronized.
Every time one goes left,
the other one goes left,
one goes up,
one goes down.
And so when I lighten this tells you,
it says,
look,
when you reach for that cup of coffee,
the universe had already decided millions of billions of years ago that that was
going to happen.
Your intuitive sense just coincides with it perfectly.
And he said that's what he calls a twin trains theory.
That the correlation theory that your desire to grab that cup of coffee doesn't
affect your hand,
does not move your hand.
That'll be impossible.
There'll be something nonphysical moving,
something physical.
So he says that they're just correlated perfectly.
When you ask them how do they correlate so perfectly,
he says,
well God,
it's like God took the girls the greatest pool shot in history.
This is like nuts.
This is a,
he's a,
he's the guy who invented the calculus,
the binary code,
you know,
like all our computers.
So they work cause of the cause of Lebanon's.
That
to me is a hard sell.
Yeah.
So most people can't wrap their mind around it.
It's a hard sell.
First of all,
he can see a woman come,
created the first computer code.
Uh,
he,
he invented the binary code binary combine they Rico,
not computer code,
but it's based on binary.
Now when he sang,
he sang this,
that your desire coincides with the universe having this.
That seems like a lot of woo.
That seems like why a bit of a stretch.
That's interesting point.
Tell me why.
Well,
why would the universe have a plan for you and your mother?
He's saying,
God,
he's saying God directly.
Well,
prove that.
Okay.
That's a great,
that's a great,
that's a great objection.
Why would you say that it would be gone?
Argument wasn't to prove God.
This argument
was to tell you that
this is a possibility.
Why you have freewill is true and so is determinism.
Yes.
Because can you deny freewill aren't you're having a direct experience of
freewill?
Well,
the only denial of freewill would be determinism.
The only denial would be that your idea of freewill is an illusion.
It's you are really shaped by the momentum of your past,
your genetics,
live experiences,
all the variables and the way you've absorbed emotions and interactions with
people and that these are flavored.
Your very being to the point when when presented with an obstacle or an
opportunity or a thing,
there is a predetermined solution in your mind for whatever the situation is.
That's determinism.
Okay,
so
let,
let's,
uh,
let's say action rather than solution.
Let's take a step back and look at what five minutes is trying to say.
Okay.
He's trying to say,
look,
there's three ways of knowing something and yeah.
Evidence that this is a brilliant human being.
Okay?
Not many,
many,
many men have said the same thing throughout history.
Let's,
let's just at least entertain it.
He says,
look,
you know something empirically through your senses.
Okay,
you touch fire,
it's hot.
Then you can know something.
Deductively one plus one equals two via logic.
Then you could know something intuitively meaning direct first experience.
Okay,
so let's,
so let's say,
let's say you tell me,
I dunno.
Um,
I've had the coffee tastes great.
You don't know that deductively or empirically the sensation of coffee tasting
great is known intuitively.
Direct meaning there is no,
um,
there is no interpreter and philosophy.
We something called the egocentric predicament.
So right now you're experiencing this entire room within your consciousness,
right?
[inaudible] I might be outside of Your Eagle,
but I'm,
I'm occurring right now in your consciousness.
Did you see the difference perceiving you saw in my consciousness or with my
consciousness,
which is connected to my senses?
Is there anything you can perceive outside of your consciousness?
That's a weird say way of saying something that's impossible,
but perceiving outside of my consciousness,
meaning not being,
not conscious,
but yet still perceiving.
No.
When you perceive something,
it has to be within your consciousness,
right?
You have to or with your consciousness,
It cannot be outside of your branch.
So even if something touches your skin,
you're consciously recognizing that it touches your skin.
Um,
the egocentric,
but they come in is more about your whole universe is made up of your
consciousness.
You cannot sense anything or experience anything or get any information outside
of your conscious.
Like cotton was very big on this.
He's like,
look this,
this is called idealism.
The whole world is happening on inside your head,
right?
Supposedly likes,
for instance,
you see this cup of coffee,
they're going to say like clusters hit the cup of coffee.
It goes into your eye,
your eye,
your eye.
It gives your brain a signal.
You're sick.
Your brain interprets the signal and creates this universe around you.
Creates this image,
the theater of your mind.
Yeah.
Can you experience anything outside the theater of your mind?
Very difficult to argue that you could.
It's impossible.
Yeah.
According to all the philosophers in history,
we,
we can't,
we cannot.
This is called the ego centric particular.
What about subconscious that be still happening inside your,
your conscious mind.
So subconscious is still somewhat conscious in some way.
Yes,
it would be happy.
Whatever.
Whatever you would perceive would be happening in your conscious mind would just
be outside of your standard awareness.
Now the scary thing is is that we have,
we make a lot of inferences and that's where the wool comes in.
Everything is will,
will you think he thinks just everything outside of sizes.
What woo sciences just as Wu was everyone else's.
You keep saying that,
but I don't understand why you're saying that because you haven't made a good
example.
Okay.
We'll only example that you said was that they changed the way they look at
gravity when new information was presented,
right.
That doesn't equal.
We'll,
we'll gravity was will.
It was a magical force.
My grandma,
my grandma,
think about gravity in terms of people that didn't even,
didn't have phones,
they didn't have cars,
they didn't have paved roads.
I mean,
you're dealing with a very primitive notion of what gravity was.
It was a very interesting idea that has since been proven to be true.
False gravity,
Newtonian gravity.
Okay.
Has been proven to be false,
but gravity is still real,
right?
Not we're using the same word for a completely different idea,
okay,
so Newton's gravity was magical.
It was an appeal to magic.
Okay.
Here it is.
Here is gravity is different than Einstein's gravity that Einstein's gravity is
what's been proven,
right?
We know now that light does bend around the mass of the sun,
which is one of the reasons why we have a hard time seeing asteroids that are
coming from behind the sun because the mass of the sun actually Ben Space Time
around it to the point where it distorts our view.
It's our new narrative.
It's not proven.
You can never prove a scientific fact past the level of hypothesis.
It's weird.
I know it sounds strange,
but what do you mean pass the level of hypothesis?
If you can prove it in studies and tests and shit,
you still don't buy it.
You have not eliminated every other possibility.
Okay,
so it's not the same as a logical flow.
How is that?
Whoa,
this is,
this is understood in,
in,
in like in the philosophy of science.
It's quick,
it's comfortable.
He accepted.
It's not anti science.
Like I'm not trying to say anything.
I know,
I know you're not.
You were saying that science has so much woo and I'm not seeing the woo.
Part of what I'm seeing is the necessary testing and the idea of incorporating
new data or heritage changing beliefs and ideas.
Again,
this is,
this is quite a,
that's a bit of a difficult thing to wrap your mind off it in one day,
but you have to think about it and throughout time [inaudible] it comes to
clearer and clearer.
When we observe the universe,
all we see is patterns and regularities found in nature.
That's it.
We don't see actual physical laws.
The physical laws are bookmarks inside our mind.
We see the same pattern over and over again,
and then we attribute a physical law,
but that physical art doesn't exist out there.
So here's,
here's a great example,
okay?
Okay.
Let me give you a great example.
Let's say I'm about to flip a coin.
Okay?
Now you're going to tell me it's probably going to land on heads or tails.
Yeah.
Do you know that logically or is it based on your history with coins?
I know it logically and based on my history of corns.
Perfect.
I'm arguing.
You don't know it logically.
You only note on your past history.
Okay?
So pay attention to this.
This is,
this is a little bit weird.
This is what we got to.
We had to go slow because it's been very weird,
okay?
It's very,
uh,
it goes against our instincts.
Okay?
Erase all your history with coins.
You've never seen a coin before.
Okay?
And I flip it right?
And now it turns into a butterfly.
You never seen a coin before.
It doesn't surprise you.
You're like,
well,
turn into a butterfly and I flip a coin a hundred times in front of you a
hundred times it turns into a butterfly.
Now I'm going to flip the coin a hundred,
the hundred and one time.
You can be like,
I bet you it turns to a butterfly.
That's how we express science.
We see the patterns and regularities.
Then we achieve.
We predict them science.
This is,
this is a little bit,
this is a good way to put it.
Science is the faith.
It's faith that the future will behave like the past.
Science is faith that the future will behave like the past.
So now you've developed a faith that this coin will flip into a butterfly
and now you can predict it.
Wouldn't you say that science is the use of measurement to understand matter and
things around us?
I wouldn't say that it's using the past to predict the future.
I would say that if you know that fire melts led at a certain temperature and
this is provable and then you can show this over and over again.
Here's what we know about fire and reaches a certain temperature.
When led reaches a certain temperature,
it melts.
It changes its form.
Whereas if you want to do that same task to carbon based steel,
it requires far greater temperatures and then we know that there's variables in
matter.
If this is,
this is not,
this is something that you can prove and show.
There's no woo to that.
Okay.
Water boils at how many degrees?
I think it's two 50 in south and southeast.
A hundred degrees Celsius.
I don't know what Fahrenheit.
Oh,
you Canadians with your wacky metric system.
Is that a side effect?
Is it a scientific fact that water boils at a certain temperature?
Yes.
Actually no,
it's not.
They can boil water now they can.
Water can resist boiling up to 200 degrees Celsius.
If you put in a certain atmosphere,
atmospheric pressure and suspended in a certain liquid.
If you change the circumstance,
suspend water in liquids,
they suspended in a particular liquid.
It's,
that's not the heated or cooled,
right?
It's not.
It's not supposed to.
It doesn't affect the temperature of the water itself.
And now water can boil at 200 degrees.
Okay,
so you're doing something different to water.
That's the thing.
You're taking it outside of the normal earth environment.
So the variables also include Earth's environment.
Agreed.
But water doesn't inherently boil at a hundred degrees.
It's not a fact.
But we believe that to be a scientific,
we believe that water,
if it gets to a hundred degrees,
is boiling.
It's going to behave this way.
As a matter of fact.
No.
There are many other things that that that fact has been debunked and there's
countless amount of facts like wait a minute,
is that the facts been debunked or is that when you add in sufficient external
variables,
then water takes longer to boil because of these variables playing into the
properties that we already observed with water.
That's why whenever we have a scientific factor,
might be new information coming to to change our view,
change our view of this fact.
Right.
This is not necessarily new information with this is his new additional precise,
more precise information.
But what you're talking about with water,
you're talking about additional variables like that's just more science.
That's not woo.
Okay,
well here's some will.
Okay.
This is cause we talk about gravity was whew,
okay random.
This was whew.
Okay.
Cause we,
we cannot find one instance of actual randomness.
The causal lightness complete us.
Laplas would say there's no randomness in the world.
So the randomness,
ideas,
just our inability to calculate exactly.
Believably difficult variables.
Exactly.
But the,
it's,
it's a projection of your ignorance.
If you knew it wouldn't be random.
So for instance,
um,
I can't remember who coined the term,
but they say the man who says the tallest mountain I've ever seen is the tallest
mountain he's making himself.
The measure of truth.
I measure truth.
If you take that perspective,
you're the center of truth.
I am truth.
There's nothing outside of me that's true.
Then you see randomness everywhere.
However,
if you believe in correspondence theory,
that truth is independent of me and you,
which I think most of us will agree,
then random has doesn't exist in that context because randomness only depends on
you and when things are true outside of your beliefs,
right?
Let's take another classic wool wool term.
And yeah,
this is a very advanced philosophy.
I know it sounds crazy,
okay?
But this is,
this is,
this is what the greatest thinkers in history,
in a report,
okay?
With what they've written down,
Okay.
See this,
uh,
you see a knife guy.
Let's look at Aristotle's theory of knives.
Okay?
Says,
look,
look at this knife.
I show you a plastic knife.
I show you a wooden knife.
I show you a metal knife,
I show you five different knives and you're like,
they're all knives.
All of them are knives.
You point to them and say their knives.
Aristotle says,
look,
they all share in one something,
let's call it the essence that makes them all knives.
Would you agree?
The form they all share,
they fight draw knife on a paper,
but like he just drew a knife.
That knife on the paper,
share something with a knife made of steel.
They'll knife made of plastic or the knife made of wood.
The form.
There's something about it.
We call it the essence in philosophy.
Okay.
The four might be confused with what Plato says split or how the whole thing
about forms,
but let's call it for now essence.
Okay.
If you change the essence,
you change the thing.
So if I take that piece of that,
if I take that plastic a knife and I melt it,
you realize it's not a knife anymore.
Why?
What did I do?
You change that thing about it.
That essence right now,
that essence,
does it exist out there in the world or is it only in your head made it up?
Well,
by calling it assence,
you're confusing me,
so I would call it the form,
the form of it.
It sort of exists in culture that exists in our understanding of these objects
and useful shapes.
It's you,
it's your,
your idea of,
of knife conforms to that knife out there.
Where's that knife out here?
That's a great,
yeah.
Bring it out.
You can see it.
Great.
It's obviously a knife.
Yes.
Right.
You recognize it or recognize it.
That's a knife.
Yeah.
I totally agree.
Mike.
Model of knife.
Yeah.
My model of knife that fits my model,
but there's some weird looking knives out there too.
Sure.
And there might be a knife where we don't agree.
That's the night you think it's a knife.
I don't agree.
That's,
I think that's a sword.
I'd reached a level of sorts.
Right.
You might have a different that that's a great evidence that something in our
minds that actually objective.
Right,
right,
right.
They get to the certain length and subjective.
It's subjective.
Right?
Okay.
Let's look up matter,
no matter.
Okay.
It's an inference of the mind.
Just like the,
the knife is an inference of the mind
in terms of subatomic particles and atoms and you see this cup,
you see this bottle?
Yes.
You see this clock?
You made an inference.
They all share one thing.
What did they share?
All of them share one thing.
What is that thing they share?
They share this thing called matter,
but that's,
that was an inference.
Just like we inferred the essence of a knife matter has never been observed in
nature.
Matter is a byproduct of our mind.
So when you see a tree,
you're not seeing matter.
There's no matter.
There's only,
not that I'm inferring matter,
I'm observing an image,
right?
But I'm insuring the matter.
The matter is,
it is a mental construct.
Is it a mental construct or is it our inability to see things smaller than what
is necessary for our survival?
Like we can't see Adam's,
we can't see subatomic particles.
We can't see them with the naked eye,
but we understand through science that they exist.
How do you understand that they exist?
Are you seeing that matter exists out there independently of your mind?
Is matter objective or is it dependent on your mind to exist?
It's not dependent on your mind to exist.
It's just dependent upon your mind to observe your,
you need your mind to be able to observe matter.
Okay.
So if you didn't exist,
do you think this table would exist?
That,
I dunno.
Right?
But what would you guess?
I would guess that all I know if I'm going to use outcomes razor,
you know,
if you've heard of aqua,
if I'm going to go to the extreme with Ockham's razor,
I'm just going to believe what I observe.
Okay.
Kill all the wool.
Kill it all.
You've had loved one die,
right?
Yeah.
Everyone has,
right?
Um,
do you assume that when they die,
the universe is still the universe?
What do you mean still the universe?
It's like the world is the way they are.
I mean,
the way it is,
there's trees and grass and dirt and this person dies.
The trees and grass,
dirt,
they don't change.
They're still the same thing.
What do you mean the nature of the tree would change it?
No,
I'm saying if you love someone and you know this person and they are no longer
with us,
all the things around you like this coughing up and this knife,
they stayed,
remained the same.
They don't change,
they don't change.
Why would you assume that it would be any different for yourself if you weren't
here?
Why would you think that this table would not exist for the microphone?
Would not say that's a great argument.
I'm not saying that it wouldn't it.
That's this is what we call hard objectivity.
Something that's hard.
Objectivity exists without any human mind and exist.
If all human minds were dead,
whatever exists still is what we would call philosophers called hard
objectivity.
Now we have objectives it.
So for instance,
let's look at George Berkeley's example.
Is that such a great question?
Look at a triangle.
Okay.
Picture a blue triangle.
Picture a green one.
Picture a black one.
Picture a white one.
Can you picture one with no subjective elements?
Meaning because color is subjective,
right?
Color is a construct of the mind.
So if I was colorblind,
this shirt would be a different color to me than it is to you.
However,
there would still be one shirt.
It would be objective to a certain degree.
Okay,
so triangle has three,
three sides,
three corners.
It adds up to 180 degrees.
We all agree it.
Whether you're colorblind,
it doesn't matter,
right?
There is no subject of element to how many points does it have?
Nobody's going to come in and say to me,
triangles have three,
four sites.
Right?
You'd be like,
that's not a triangle.
There's not three angles to that.
You've not.
You've gone past it a little cool understanding.
Okay,
so can you,
George Berkeley says,
can you picture a triangle without any subjective element,
without any color?
Let's call it color.
To make it really simple,
really,
really obvious.
Can you picture a triangle without any color?
You would have to have it in contrast to something so that you could see it.
Like if you had a say,
if you had a purple curtain,
like what we have behind us,
and out of that Purple Carton,
we cut a triangle.
Even if there was no color,
if it was just clear,
you would be able to see.
You'd be able to differentiate between that shape,
but she needed that purple curtain to differentiate so we cannot have it without
subjective element.
This was Berkeley's point.
Exactly what you said.
I see what you're saying.
Beautiful.
Every objective thing we've observed in the universe has,
this is made up of subjective elements.
Even when you draw the number one on a blackboard,
it has to be a color as to be something that has to be a contrast.
Like you said,
it's beautiful.
He said it beautifully.
All our objective elements or mental constructs,
three sides.
The idea of side is a mental construct.
The idea of a point is a mental construct.
The idea of 180 degrees is mathematical.
It's happening in your mind somewhere.
They're being observed.
You can draw it and I can see it and I can repeat it and you can teach it to me
and I can teach it to someone else like these are,
they may be mental constructs,
but they're provable mental that
are repeatable.
So there we were.
Sharing agreement is a real thing.
We're in agreement that mathematic is a mental construct and it's true.
It's definitely by the finish and truth.
So it was both a mental construct and trust,
but it's not outside out there in the world.
It's within.
But if you make a triangle on the ground,
it's in the world.
The numbers are in your head and the subjective element is in the world.
There's a two way street.
The subjective element is in the world,
but it's a triangle.
So,
so how's it in your head?
Because you,
when you look at a triangle,
the subjective elements,
when you observe them in your mind,
your mind points out different objective elements of that triangle.
But it's dependent on your mind.
By that argument,
the entire universe is dependent on your mind.
Absolutely no doubt about it.
If we're going to use OCKHAM's razor,
yes,
but not everyday language.
We use an outcomes.
Let's take away everything.
We're not sure of everything that has a doubt.
Get rid of it.
Okay?
Get rid of everything with a sliver of the La you ever heard or read.
The problem and they can't matter itself as a sliver of doubt.
Absolutely.
Well,
when you have subatomic particles that you know they exist in two different
states simultaneously.
They're both spinning and still there in superstates Berkeley would tell you
those are images of subatomic particles.
They're not mum.
Some of sub atomic particles independent of your mind.
Well,
I had a conversation with Sean Carroll about it.
It was a physicist and he made it familiar,
even more muddy to me.
I thought I,
I thought it was crazy before I talked to him and then when I talked to him,
he's brilliant,
he's brilliant.
He's essentially saying that subatomic particles don't blink in and out of
existence.
It's just we,
it's the way we're looking at them and that they exist in this just bizarre
state,
but they exist in this state in a way that it's very difficult for us to use
normal language to sort of explain.
Exactly.
That's,
that's the true issue.
But you know what a,
I might have fucked.
He's probably listening to this was like you fucking dummy.
You know,
and what I said again,
you know what is,
what a great w one great conversation.
I heard a conversation between Jordan Peterson and Sam Harris,
all that,
the conversation about truth.
I loved it.
Oh,
that drove me crazy.
I think we could do better though.
Yes.
I think they could have done better to the moderator.
Yes,
exactly.
Exactly.
Do you need to get to know each other personally first?
They never met,
by the way.
That's,
that's fireworks,
right?
That was such a great conversation.
But here's my question.
What's the difference between knowledge and belief?
Because a lot of what we said is kind of muddy.
Okay,
let's make it suit.
Let's make,
let's make the water's crystal clear as much as possible.
Okay.
What is the difference between knowledge and belief?
Well,
the belief that the gremlins are pulling down on people,
which is why we have gravity.
That would be a belief.
No,
they're both beliefs.
Well,
Dad,
gravity's not knowledge.
It's a belief.
Okay,
but we're talking about Graham ones.
I was gonna say that's knowledge or that that's a belief.
Belief,
knowledges.
If I throw water on your,
you get wet.
Hmm.
How would say that's belief to believe?
Yes.
So maybe one day I throw water on you and you to show me that you're Jesus and
the water just goes right through you and it does.
The reason why you believe of water,
it would make me wet is because it happened in the past.
Now you think that the future is going to behave like the past.
Just like Aristotle saw the sun go around the earth and he thought that this is
going to happen everyday.
He didn't understand.
I understand.
It's optical illusion.
Let me,
let me go.
Let me give you a better is though.
It's each to throw it out.
She get wet.
All flamingos are pink.
They're not.
We didn't know that all the time.
Did we?
Then we went to Australia.
They don't have the same food source.
They don't have the same food sorts of their black here.
They're white here.
They have a different food source.
Flamingos are not inherently pink.
It's a scientific fact can always be overturned.
Never.
Look at this.
He threw a water and didn't get wet.
Yeah,
but this is not just because it's a,
it's a certain coding.
Right.
I got you.
But if he's got that over his body,
not going to be able to breathe.
Okay.
How about this?
You've never seen fire before.
You've never seen five K and human being.
You've been being warmed by electric blankets your entire life.
Okay.
Then you see a flame and you don't know.
Can you know that that flame is going to burn you if you touch it logically or
is it only via experience?
Through history,
developing a history or relationship with fire.
A bird you once at burns you twice.
You're like,
Hey,
but I think the future is going to behave like the past.
I'm not gonna touch that.
Folk who know that fire burns you and they've never been burned by fire because
they went to school and they learn from people who explain the properties of
fire,
what it is,
how it works,
what temperature it operates on,
how it's different depending upon the color of it or what's burning.
Borrowed history,
borrowed history.
It's still history.
Borrowed history.
How you learned from my mistakes of touching fire.
Okay,
but it's still known VR experience for your history.
Well,
it's known via science.
If you explain exactly what the elements of the fire are and how it works and
what it burns at and what temperature specific things need to burn out,
you don't have to get burned to know that it will burn you.
No,
no,
but that's how we discovered fire burns by testing it,
not via logical deduction.
Okay,
I see what you're saying.
It's only history.
Science is pattern is irregularities found in nature.
We observe nature.
We see these patterns and regularities.
Right.
We have no idea what's causing them.
Well,
it wasn't that day cards.
Original idea about science in the first place was using measurement to sort of
understand nature well was on one of his original concepts of establishing
science in the first place.
No,
his original concept was it.
They look,
science is doubtable.
He said that science is doubtable.
No.
Dot.
It's called Cartesian dealt in extreme level of doubt.
He says those are all beliefs.
I don't have any knowledge.
What do I,
what do I know?
Because knowledge means zero chance of being wrong.
Okay,
zero chance of being wrong.
Give me one scientific fact.
You truly trust 100% okay.
If I take a match and I take a yellow piece of paper from this particular
notebook,
I will light that motherfucker file at that match.
That's a fact.
Okay.
That's a site that we fact is it?
No,
it's a scientific fact,
but it's not higher than hypothesis is just hypothesis you up.
Why?
Because every time you've seen a fire touch of piece of paper,
it burned it.
So you're relying on your historical experiences essentially saying there's no
scientific fact possible.
Only to the level of hypothesis we can,
oh,
this is not me talking and this is Thomas Quinn.
I shouldn't be saying,
look,
he's saying,
we have two phases in science,
standards,
science,
and then a scientific revolution.
What Standard Science?
Well,
whatever the flavor of the day is.
Let's say today it's,
let's hit the dates evolution,
and then he said,
look,
every every piece of information that we receive,
we interpreted through that Lens.
He called it a paradigm.
We look at the information through the lens of evolution so it makes sense.
It fits right here in our story of evolution,
right?
And then he says,
look,
a small amount of contradictory information is gonna Pool.
Slowly
it's inevitable.
He says,
and then this,
we're gonna ignore it.
We're going to sweep it under the rug.
Everything doesn't make sense.
And then one day,
that level of information that,
that amount of information that doesn't fit in any way with our theory or
current theory is going to pull and pull and pull and pull until one guy comes
around and says,
no,
we had a backwards.
Are we headed the wrong?
It's this and now all this new information fits in the new theory.
All the old stuff fits in.
All the new stuff fits.
And that's called the scientific revolution.
And he says,
science scientists always going through a normal phase and then a revolution
phase and man is becoming more and more precise but will never reach the level
of past hypothesis.
Why?
Because science is based on our faith that their pass,
excuse me,
that the future will behave like the past.
We only know things via experience,
VR history,
so when I flipped that coin,
you have no idea what's going to happen until I flipped many coins in front of
you or I give you my,
if you trust me and I tell you what,
listen,
I did this experiment.
Here are my results and you trust me.
You just take it for granted.
You take it on way of authority.
I agree with everything you said.
I still don't see where you're saying science has so much.
Whew.
Okay.
Or science has as much woo as healers or crystals,
suckers or listen,
I don't believe in crystals in any of that.
I know you don't.
I don't.
I just,
I have a higher standard of skepticism.
I'm missing the Wu though.
Okay.
The Wu is when we project physical laws,
combustion,
electricity,
gravity,
these are all appealed to magic.
Can you demonstrate these,
these physical laws or are they byproducts?
Are they,
are they inferences you made in your mind because you've seen a certain pattern
over and over again.
That law doesn't exist out there in the universe.
It's only a bookmark.
It's only a name we have for a pattern we've observed in nature.
It was pretty heavy stuff.
I know it's only a name for a pattern exactly that we've observed that exists in
nature.
Exactly,
so that means you can't label anything ever because the everything is just a
pattern that we've observed in nature.
Everything.
Everything is a pattern.
There is no,
there's no logic behind.
Nothing's neurologic.
We give an explanation,
we give a narrative to it.
Okay,
but that narrative is just our paradigm.
Comscore would say that's the shades you're wearing.
Okay,
that's you.
You can't set a beautiful,
he said,
look,
you have pink tinted glasses.
You could have blue tinted glasses,
but whatever glasses you're wearing,
that's the song and dance.
That's the,
that's the,
that's the story you tell yourself of why those things are happening,
the way they're happening.
Okay.
The truth of the matter is all we're seeing is one pattern happening over and
over again.
So what this is,
is essentially as an intellectual exercise,
but the reality of our ability to come up,
well not ours,
obviously super smart people come up with the very technology that we're using
right now to broadcast this podcast means that they have figured things out,
that there are provable and that you can use science to determine what frequency
things need to be,
how much electricity you need,
what kind of components can you know,
take the image and projected through the power lines and through the Internet
coat cables and all the different things that we need to be in place to provide
the electricity to provide the Internet connection.
That's all science.
So this is all predictive sciences,
predictive,
right?
But this is all,
these are all things that are not just observable,
but they're repeatable,
right?
The pattern.
Where's the woo here?
Here's,
here's where the rule is.
Okay.
Our explanation for why it happens,
the laws of nature are woo.
It's not woo is,
are our words that we use to describe repeatable things.
Okay.
Which which,
which law of which force of of of nature are you referring to?
Let's pick one.
Lucky,
random miss.
Can you show?
I don't think that is a force of nature.
Okay,
so three with you.
That randomness.
The idea of randomness.
Okay.
Pick one because they use it.
They say it's,
it's evolution of a natural section via a random selection of temperature.
Temperature.
Okay.
What causes to I observe temperature like you,
I believe temperature exists.
What causes temperature?
We don't know.
That's true and we don't know we you and I don't know [inaudible] they don't
have any idea what causes only tell me about the patterns and regularities.
That's it.
That friction causes certain things that the magnetic pull of the sun on the
earth causes a certain temperature shifts and the these are recognizable and
repeatable and they understand how to measure them.
These are all just patterns and regularities found in nature and they're giving
them names and explanations.
I see what you're saying.
Isn't explanations be debunked later on?
I put them in the maybe bio plausible pile,
but this is,
this is,
listen,
I know it's frustrating but the philosophy of science,
this is it.
The cause and effect.
We do not observe cause and effect.
We do not observe one thing causing another and we just see a and then we see B.
It's really,
it's really,
it's a bit difficult but imagine this,
we see and we see B,
we don't,
we don't see the causal connection cause if we did see the causal connection you
would know what happens.
When I flipped that coin,
you could have predicted it.
You called predict what's going to happen when I file exactly how much force
you're exerting on your thumb.
To flip that coin,
I would have to know what altitude we're at to understand what the atmosphere
that this coin is going through.
I would have to know the weight of the coin.
I would have to know that the position of your thumb on the thing,
it's like what you said about the billiard balls,
that it is true that if you could calculate the exact amount of friction on the
cloth and the table,
the amount of Polish that are on the balls,
the amount of force,
you'd have to have all the balls in exactly the same spot,
but this is,
this is not possible today.
Today if you set up a table and you set up,
let's say just say nine balls and you told me you were going to know where every
ball was to the millimeter,
I would say I will bet you $1 million you're wrong and I would be right every
time.
You're never going to get it.
Why?
Because you don't have the ability to calculate all those very,
but it's theoretically portion.
It's also the physical,
the physical change of the amount of force that you drive when you break those
balls varies and it varies even slightly.
It's going to change the way so a person just doing it with their body is not
capable of that kind of precision.
If we got a robot to break,
even if you've got a robot to break,
you would have to have those balls in exactly the same spot and they don't
usually sit that way because the cloth has fiber in it and it's wool.
It's a worsted wool and at worst it will moves and shifts and bends and it
flattens out in some spaces and other spaces.
It gets dirt and debris.
In Charleston,
there's too many variables.
So because we cannot compute all the variables,
I'm with you.
We can,
maybe we can create a to it with a slight margin of error.
Right?
Well,
they'll still be a margin of error.
That's why I said I need a divine calculator.
Don't have to even round off the numbers so I'll be slightly wrong.
Right.
But the argument is that if we had all the variables and that's a big,
if it's logically possible,
it's logically coherent with the reality that we see.
Yes.
Random.
This is by the wayside.
It's a figment of our imagination.
We projected when we cannot compute,
but if we could,
this is a objective outside of us,
right?
The truth is outside of a,
it's not dependent on me and you how we see the world.
So randomness is based essentially on our inability to calculate variables.
It's not on the,
on an actual law itself.
When we pray,
when we say that's random,
it's wool,
right?
It is and the strictest way of the,
of the word.
Now,
every logical law.
Now this,
this,
this is what hurts people,
but I love science.
Look at me.
I'm,
I'm a lover of Sinai and I'm a,
I'm a,
I'm a science addict,
okay?
I read all the books.
I am fascinated by science.
Let's say I take object x and I throw it at that.
I throw it at a window.
What's going to happen?
You don't know or have any experience with object.
Object.
Object is why can't you?
Why can't you deduce it?
Why can't you do this?
What's going to happen if I had more information than you need experience.
You need a history with object x.
You need to get to know object x,
interact.
You cannot deduce it.
While you would write down all these different variables,
you would find out what people have learned from the past about these variables
and now we'd be science.
Exactly.
Science is the history of patterns and regularities.
It is not,
deduction is not logic.
It's the type of lighter we call inductive logic.
This logic is the faith that the past than the future.
Soon in the future it will behave like the past.
So the patterns and regularities we see in nature,
we say,
look,
if these happen often enough,
we can recreate these circumstances.
Often enough,
we predict it will happen in the future.
We have a faith that it'll happen again in the future.
There is no logical reason why it does.
There is no not one single logical reason why we don't fall off the fall off,
fall off the face of the earth.
Every explanation we give ourselves is just a narrative.
It is always subject to interpretation.
However,
with the change in variables like Chyna shifting of the Earth's magnetic poles
or I gave you a ridiculous narrative,
the Gremlin one,
just to show you,
look,
I know you don't believe in mine.
I don't believe in my neither,
right,
but I'm doing the same thing Isaac did and I'm going to correlate my Grumman's
three as far as he can correlate his gravity theory.
He used the word gravity.
He made it.
He made it sound better.
He made it sound less ridiculous,
but the truth of matter is he's throwing his hands up in the air and saying,
look,
I dunno,
let's just call it gravity.
Let's,
this is the way to think about it.
Now.
His contemporaries laughed at him.
They said,
it's an appeal to magic,
and then when people started wearing those shades,
those paradigms,
they're like,
hey,
it makes sense if you,
if you believe,
if you,
if you just believe in gravity for a second,
it explains all this ballet of,
of celestial bodies and how they move,
but really what he discovered was a pattern and he gave that pattern in name,
but does that force exists out there?
Well,
not according to Einstein.
He came up with a different narrative that fits the evidence even better than
than Isaac Newton did.
But it's still a narrative.
It's,
it hasn't removed all the other possibilities for something to be true.
Without a doubt.
For it to be knowledge,
not belief.
There has to be zeroed out,
meaning no other possibility whatsoever.
That's knowledge.
So my,
so can you know something that's untrue?
You cannot know something that's untrue.
You could believe something that's untrue.
Knowledge means that this is known.
There is no possibility of doubt.
That's why Descartes was such an important philosopher because he gave us one
thing that we know the cogito.
Have you heard of the Cogito?
I don't remember what it is.
I think therefore I am.
Oh,
okay.
What is it that we know for sure cause cause uh,
you know it's funny,
there's two great philosophies that I've read that they went through a crisis in
their life.
One of them was MMO has Elliot agreed Arabic philosopher and one of them was
only they kept and both their writings are very like they're,
it's amazing.
Why?
Because they go through this crisis,
they go through,
what do I actually know?
What's not?
Because they came to this exact same conclusion that hey,
it's all song and it's all as explanation.
It's not proof.
It's all a narrative.
It's all a point of view.
Science keeps getting refined and changed.
What we more information,
what we believed yesterday gets taken out from underneath us.
Today's paradigms going to be shifted again a hundred years from now,
a thousand years from now.
What can I grab and be like,
this is true.
Nobody can ever take this from me.
That's going to be called knowledge.
So it all comes down like at the end,
at the end of the long journey of Cartesian doubt,
he was,
it was so extreme that the philosophers give it a new name.
They call it Cartesian dot.
They call it modern philosophy.
So philosophy is thousands of years old.
Descartes comes,
writes a book,
he wrote six chapters in six days and he was like,
what do I actually know?
100% without a doubt,
nobody could ever question me.
And he said,
look,
I believe in the Cognito.
What's the Kogi too?
I think therefore I am.
So he goes through a long process.
You know,
if we have the time,
we'll,
we'll go through.
A little nutshell of it says,
look is look,
when I,
when I put a straw in a glass of water,
my eyes tell me that the straw is bent,
right?
Cause the reflection of the waters is bent.
The light,
the reflection of the light off the water is bent.
Yeah.
He says,
look,
my eyes light to me.
Aristotle thought the sun goes around the earth,
his eyes light to him.
Our senses lie.
And he talks about if I put my hand in cold water,
then I put it in tepid water.
They'll seem warm to me.
But that's just my bias.
My inability to tell you what my,
my,
my instruments are not accurate enough.
So he said,
okay,
let's,
let's put the
empiricism or senses by the wayside.
CanNot give us truth.
Can I give us truth?
He says,
what about deduction?
What about math?
And the local knowledge,
one plus one equals two.
Believe it or not,
philosophers also disagree with a lot of mathematical,
uh,
beliefs.
So for instance,
here's a,
here's a big critique of math.
Okay?
One plus one equals two.
We all believe it.
But the critique is that one plus one is another way of saying too,
there's no actual information you ever gave me.
Mathematics is just one way to sum up a lot of information.
It helps me give you an epiphany.
It makes,
it makes me,
it helps me make you understand what's happening on the billiard ball table.
We'll give you a calling,
one plus one two.
You're not changing the objects themselves in.
It's always been two things always been too.
Yeah,
it's a tautology.
You're just explaining to me something that's out there already existing.
So if I tell you a triangle has three points,
why when I said the word triangle,
I already told you how three points,
but maybe you didn't pick that up.
Maybe you had to point that out to you.
So Bertrand Russell said it beautifully,
said look first in his career,
Burton Russel is a very,
uh,
he's a great thinker.
He said,
look,
mathematics is the thing we're more sure of.
By the end of his career,
he was like,
guys,
I'm not even sure about math anymore.
Why?
He's like,
I think math is just another way of seeing a four legged animal has is an
animal,
but you said that when you said it's four legged animal,
and he just repeated yourself by saying it's an animal.
If I say there's my wife,
I married her when I said my wife,
I told you I married her.
That's what math is doing.
Math is giving you the information again,
in a simpler form that you can understand and you think,
oh,
I've deduced this instrument.
No,
actually the information was there in the question,
right?
Some,
some philosophers disagree with this.
They said,
no,
a math brings you like can't,
can't said no.
Math tells you something.
Okay,
let's put that on the waste side.
Here's another critique.
One I've personally could never get around is say,
look.
He says,
look,
all of the greatest thinkers in history,
there's actually an urban Timia critique of logic.
He says,
look,
all the greatest thinkers in history all disagree like Plato and Aristotle.
Plato tutored Aristotle,
two of the greatest thinkers in ancient history.
They don't agree with one another.
They do.
They both think they will say you're wrong.
And then like I said,
I'm on.
Okay,
fast forward.
Every generation,
their greatest thinkers disagreed.
Lightness didn't agree with Voltaire Today,
Sam Harris and and Jordan Peterson to,
okay,
maybe they're not the top topic lectures of our war of our on Earth Day,
but there are there among the,
among the elite.
They don't agree on what is true.
When you ask them what's truth,
you guys are talking about truth all day long.
Can you define it for us?
We don't agree.
So if logic is something that tells us about the world,
if it is,
let's say we grant that they card saying,
look,
we can't use it.
We don't.
Nobody's good enough to use it and get to a conclusion that everybody agrees
upon.
So he's saying,
look,
even that doesn't help me.
So he came up to the Cogito,
he says,
look,
he doubted everything.
Like even went to the point where he said,
what if I'm dreaming?
What if there's a evil demon or they're always tricky?
My,
he went really out there like he,
that's one of the reasons why simulation theory is to what people really do,
what series people consider the potential that not only is it possible that we
are in a simulation,
but that there are many,
many simulations inside of simulations because we couldn't.
That's what the egocentric predicament we were talking about earlier is you can
not experience anything outside of your consciousness,
so you could be plugged into a machine right now and this is just a big old
dream could be,
and that's why Descartes wanted to know what would be true.
Even if I was in a simulator and that's I think therefore I am,
therefore I am because for me to have thoughts,
I'd have to exist.
If you doubt the Kogi till you've proved the Cognito gets to object to it,
you first have to have existence Bryant,
right?
He refined it,
I think.
I think thinkers refined that later on and before him.
Also many thinkers came to this conclusion.
He just did it really famously.
He did it.
We did it in one sentence too.
He did it in one sentence.
He summed it up.
That's why if you,
you know,
I've heard of Ockham's razor.
If you use Ockham's razor to an extra,
if you go create,
if you go to an extreme degree,
if you everything with adult,
you chop it,
everything did might be imaginary,
inferred,
logical,
empirical.
You Chop it.
What happens?
You have a transcendent experience.
You'd become you if you take off all your paradigms,
and this takes a very brave human being to do,
to remove everything that anybody's ever told you and have the experience of the
one thing,
what you would know,
what you would come to with with mystics.
That's why I believe that there's,
there's a place where you can get where religion is true and science has faith
and I know it sounds crazy,
but there is a point and I believe in science,
don't get me wrong,
I'm a,
I can't pray science enough,
but there is a transcendent experience a human has and that transcendent
experience is consciousness itself,
not the content of consciousness.
This is where people make a mistake.
Consciousness itself,
reality.
Your world is nested in consciousness.
People think conscious is within my brain.
It's the opposite.
Your brain,
your body,
your uh,
your,
your self is in consciousness.
And when we,
when we get to this point,
then all our paradox is disappear.
There's no more paradox.
The logical paradox is movement.
Maybe if we have time,
we talked biological paradoxes.
They never end.
But when we,
we understand that our world is nested in consciousness,
there's nothing happening in the world around you that's outside of your
consciousness.
It's only outside of your eagle.
The thing you would you associate with Joe Rogan
is also happening inside your consciousness.
Your brain is within consciousness.
No Brene has ever been observed outside of consciousness.
See and flow in materialism.
We have this,
they have this philosophy called Epi for nominalism that the consciousness is a
byproduct of this physical brain.
We have this physical brain and your consciousness is like a byproducts,
like a smoke.
Now we asked them,
how do you know about this physical brain?
All we know it because of our consciousness.
So if your consciousness is fake,
unreal,
then souls,
your brain,
your brain's x.
The reason why we all know about brains is because of conscious consciousness
tells us about brains.
So brains are dependent on consciousness,
not consciousness dependent on the brain.
So I know this is a bit of a tricky thing,
but this is what idealism is all about.
There is no physical object outside of consciousness.
It's all mental construct.
This is d,
this is what we,
this is a,
we started this podcast talking about it and we ended on a mind.
Fuck.
Yeah,
seriously.
This is a serious mind.
Fuck the egocentric predicament.
Not In an not an easy one.
Well,
it's uh,
it's,
it's a fascinating yet impractical exercise because you will,
you will do it to the end of the time we'd be sitting here debating and
discussing and dissecting the very,
but you know,
that's also how you gain a greater
and deeper understanding of all the things you have no idea what the fuck they
are.
Exactly.
But it's,
it's still,
it's still amazing to me.
Like,
how much is to be explored about what is real around this,
like the world,
the reality of the world around us is it's,
it's,
it's greater than any mystery in existence.
That's why for me,
I can't read fiction.
I only study science,
history,
philosophy.
That's the only thing.
Science,
history,
philosophy,
religion.
Cause it's weird enough.
No,
because it,
they're all trying to tell me they all trying to explain the world around us and
it's such a hard thing to do.
To sum up what's,
what's reality.
Hey,
all these philosophies and theories are trying to sum it up.
This is reality.
And to cross examine them for me is far more entertaining than watching a movie
or hearing a fictional story.
Yeah,
no,
I get it.
I mean,
it's definitely fascinating and entertaining and uh,
I,
I like fictional stories too though.
I like,
I like observing creativity because I'm fascinated by the human experience and
I'm fascinating by what people were able to
okay.
Create out of their own mind.
Something like we were talking yesterday about Stephen King about how amazing it
is that this guy just keeps continuing to create these bizarre stories and that
someone can do that.
The your consciousness and by putting so much emphasis on creativity and your
ability to just write down things that never really happened and paint a picture
inside someone's mind.
Yeah.
Let me ask you this.
If he is,
if determinism is true,
who wrote the stories?
Like when you're Reddick has passed,
when you're right,
uh,
when you write a story on a computer,
did the computer write the story?
No.
You wrote the story,
right?
But if determinism is true,
Stephen is just the computer and his buttons are being pushed by past events.
Yeah.
So that's why like one student asks me,
Hey,
you should read a book by Sam Harris on determinism.
Like,
well,
can you ask Sam who wrote the book?
You know,
who wrote the book on the terrorism is going to say,
well he did.
Now he can write it.
Anything.
He's determined so that these are old philosophical questions that need to be
explored.
But they are,
like you say,
a mind bending,
you know,
very mind bending for us.
I'm glad we finally get this man to me too.
Like we can do about a hundred of sure.
Let's do it again,
man.
How often are you in town?
Ah,
rarely,
but next time I'm in Vegas for UFC or something,
I'll make take a trip over to do it.
Do it.
Thank you sir.
Appreciate it,
man.
It was great for Rasa.
Hobby,
Ladies and gentlemen.
Oh,
sorry man.